Hello, hello, moi moi boo!
Oh wait, I think my chat has frozen for me.
I see somebody saying Minto likes Metal Gear, I see.
We'll keep that away.
Hello everybody, hi!
Well now I'm unfreezing you.
There we go.
Is that me?
No.
It's not me.
I don't know.
I'm back?
Wait, did I go out?
Wait, are you...
Hello!
Hello, hello, hello, hello, hello, hello, hello.
I dropped for a sec.
Spooky.
So spooky.
Hopefully all is fun.
Oh, hiyao!
Hi, everybody.
Sundress of Minky in Waterpark Simulator!
It's like the most summery time ever.
Hi, Minto had a great time meeting on Upkai.
I had the Fuma with the pacifier.
Let's meet again soon.
Seta card!
Thank you.
You absolutely did have the pacifier.
Oh my gosh.
Pan soap and I just went to the little ghosties room.
I don't like the smell.
It's like... Oh my...
There was... What was it?
Oh my gosh.
The hotel that we were staying at?
No.
The hotel I stayed in after off, Kai.
I did not like the soap.
It smelled like... It smelled like an axe body spray.
It smelled like a... like a man's cologne.
It was so strong.
That's kind of...
Similar to this.
Hello, Minto and I boost like you!
It is now day three of monitoring the status of the lettuce
parasite.
I saw your tweet, Colmo.
I'm safe for now, steering clear of Taco Bell until further
notice.
Colmo Akiba over there.
That's the worst.
Too strong of smell.
Manly, Minto.
Check out these goods.
bacon too wait regular bacon right because I just bought
turkey bacon wait wait wait I just bought I just bought
bacon yesterday wait it's it's not turkey bacon right it's
only regular bacon
no berries and grapes now too wait I just bought berries
yesterday I bought, wait, eggs, blueberries.
Wait, I just bought eggs.
It's true.
Wait, no, wait.
I just bought, I bought a bag of frozen berries, and I
bought eggs.
And I bought, if
it happens, it happens.
If it happens, it happens.
Thank you so much for the bread.
Thank you so much.
I'm blaming your cuteness for how much I bought at Off-Kai.
Here's to hoping I'll get a meet and greet eventually.
You will, Siegel.
We have to meet.
We have to.
Anytime I don't meet someone, I have to meet them.
It's in the books.
I found out I was allergic to my Off-Kai hotel soap.
I should stop simply tanking it.
Oh no, I had a BLT at San Jose Airport.
Help!
Oh gosh!
No!
Official Ayami Minto's Good's new Zune music album and lots
and lots of KC 108 is going to be stacked.
Hope you have lots of fun.
Yeah!
Thank you.
I'm very excited.
I'm very sorry I'm taking another Japan trip.
I hope you guys understand that at first I wasn't going to
go.
At first I wasn't going to go.
I was just like, oh it's so cool.
My mama is the illustrator for Comic-Cat.
me Concrut!
But at least I got Maureen, that means I'm more Georgian!
Also, thank you for the five.
Gifted!
Thank you.
No, feel better.
Feel better.
Thank you guys for all the gifts.
Thank you so much.
Thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you.
Thank you.
It's okay, you mentioned wanting to go to Comic-Cat months
ago, too.
Yeah, I was, um, very...
I was very subtly trying to hint at it.
months ago I was like you guys if Comic-Cat this year if you
would want to go to Comic-Cat maybe maybe you should go but
I think Winter Comic-Cat will also be cool
so I might try for Winter Comic-Cat as well Good morning,
Mito!
Looking forward to Komike!
And thank you!
Me too!
Thank you!
Smiles at you.
Smiles back at you.
Yes!
So...
Smiling back at you.
Drawing my wallet's tears knowing I will not change.
No.
Comic-CAN this summer I'd rather go to boot camp.
Don't say that.
Though it will be quite hot.
Actually.
Oh my gosh.
Have you seen the weather in Japan lately?
It's like 40 degrees Celsius.
legitimately it's so it's so hot um but i will be going to
japan uh oh my gosh is that it's not next week is it wait
what am i going no it's not next week in two weeks i'm going
back to japan and then uh and then skyline serenade 40 c yes
40 c 40 c actually let's see what if i go to tokyo right now
what time is it in japan it's it's 8 a.m it's 8 a.m and it's
33 degrees
wait wait i'm gonna that's hard dog i'm gonna come back a
puddle say me thank you there miss phantom me that's me i am
writing to inform you of the legal action i I am taking
against you.
Your new song, Ramesh's Summer is too catchy and is
interfering with my ability to think about it.
I will be seeking damages totaling $67 million.
You have to prove that you have lost $67 million first.
33C in the morning.
33C at 8 a.m.
Insane.
I feel like the temp here was 120 Fahrenheit the other day.
It's crazy.
It is a hot, hot summer.
Hot, hot summer.
I wish I was back in San Jose.
The weather was so nice there.
It was, wasn't it?
It was quite...
Actually, I say that, but I did not get to go outside very
much.
So, actually, I have no idea how the temperature was.
San Jose was only in the 80s, mostly.
Nice, nice, nice.
California was such a great break from Florida heat.
actually when i went to disneyland afterwards which is la it
was so humid which is so rare for california no i was like
why why is it so why am i sticky hot ghost summer stay cool
i'm inky you too nexi
No, sticky.
Oh, sticky.
It was terrible.
Terrible, terrible.
San Jose was nice to experience because Florida Heat was so
true.
I hope everybody is able to find ways to stay cool.
No.
It's been pretty humid in SoCal lately.
It's strange.
That is weird.
Hmm.
Yeah.
Good thing all the merch helps you stay fresh.
What does that mean?
I did get a package.
though from like Setsuna fan mail stuff and things from
Faname and things from Ofkai I felt like Christmas I felt
like Christmas it was crazy one thing that was really nice
is Hebi Hebi the artist that I collabed with for the for the
song for Tomb Raider Tomb Raider King she gave me a little
gift bag and she gave me so much stuff from korea it was so
sweet it was so so sweet 26 pound package how did you know
that wait how did you know that are they leaking things in
the discord she loves you she's so nice i oh i said so oh
i'm the one leaking it wait i'm leaking sorry it Right
before this, I had like a serious meeting.
And so my brain is like mush at the moment.
Everything's fine.
Kind of.
But my brain is mush.
Mush, mush, mush, mush, mush, mush, mush, mush.
I can't believe I said it.
He is giving her dementia.
I've had dementia a long time ago.
But yeah, it felt like Christmas.
I got so many things.
It was so nice.
I was like, oh my gosh.
I would open something up and I'd be like, oh my gosh.
I open something else.
I'd be like, oh my gosh.
What kind of serious meetings do VTubers get into?
Honestly, there's so much happening behind the scenes that I
can never say.
I love your model, you might not respond.
I really love watching your streams.
I'm responding!
Thank you!
I see your comments.
Oh, hi.
Oh, geez.
Don't spam, don't spam.
Yeah, there's so much going on.
I try to like, I try to give lots of people grace, you know,
because things that, when I see how much is going on behind
the scenes of what I'm doing, I'm like, You know, it's one
of those things where it's like, you never really know
what's happening out there.
Hi, singular not spamming.
Send this guy away.
Put this guy behind bars.
Get in the pool, stinky.
I think pools make you not smell good.
I think they're full of chemicals.
Chlorine.
I'm being observed.
Yeah, I'm observing, I'm observing.
Just wanted to say that I will be embarking on my four-year
journey to become a teacher next week.
Whoa!
I hope you'll keep us, me, company along the way, me to
love!
Reach lol!
Good luck!
Oh my gosh, a teacher!
Wait, in what?
In what?
What are you going to be teaching?
P and chemicals.
Hopefully...
Hopefully the chemicals are strong enough to...
You know, to...
To...
Overpower the other...
Thing.
There was... What was it though?
I smelled...
You ever smell...
sunscreen?
You ever smell sunscreen and you're like...
It smells nostalgic.
And you're like, wow, the smell of summer is just the smell
of sunscreen.
You ever eat sunscreen?
Maybe.
The chlorine doesn't smell on its own, by the way.
Wait, really?
Smell of the beads.
Yes, yes, yes.
I want to call it nostalgic.
I use it often enough.
not I use sunscreens from like Asia I use sunscreens from
Asia because sunscreen in the US is like the sunscreen laws
are heavily outdated so um if you can like get your
sunscreen from elsewhere if you smell chlorine it's because
it's reacted a lot to ammonia.
No!
Wait, really?
Wait, that's horrifying.
Wait, that's... Please don't tell me that's real.
Please tell me factor fiction.
Wait, we made it up.
No.
Please tell me that's fake.
It's made up.
There's no way.
It also reacts to sweat.
Maybe.
I guess I guess that's fair.
Right?
you know not this time we made it up this one was created by
our writers you know actually i was watching factor fiction
i've been watching the episodes recently that was one of my
favorite shows as a wee wee ghost with my grandma my grandma
and i we would watch like we watch like every single episode
together factor fiction beyond belief factor fiction it is
so awesome Hi Minto, it is I, X Dude Awesome.
You're back!
X Dude Awesome!
We were waiting for you.
Good old Jonathan Freak.
It was such a fun show, right?
Oh, so good.
I've been watching the episodes for free on YouTube.
Thank you, thank you!
Drenna!
Thank you!
Hi Minto!
and the Residenzitude at the EXC.
A big congratulations on your phenomenal performance.
Thank you.
I wasn't able to see it live, but I'll catch the pod.
Yes, please, please.
Super happy for you all.
Hope and congratulations to you and the yummy mama as well.
Thank you.
We're going to share that we got Vash's ashes, but we'll
have a...
Be having a dinner to celebrate his life.
You and Stream will contribute to cheerful vibes.
Cheerful vibes!
Cheerful, cheerful, cheerful, cheerful.
I hope you have a great dinner, Casey.
Meow.
Pinto, your Oshi loves Star Trek featuring Jonathan Frakes.
Won't you give it a shot?
Well, Mike's the class up!
I'm Rich Evans.
I like Mike.
Well, I can't say.
They're real people.
so weird being like, I like Mike more than rich.
No, I love all of Red Letter Media.
I love all of Red Letter Media.
I don't know.
I've...
Is it weird that, like, long time ago, I was, like, an
elitist nerd?
And I would be, like...
I like anime.
I don't like that nerd's stuff, like, Star Trek.
I did not watch lot of stuff with real people but then at
the same time i didn't read comics so
but i think uh it it's it i hate that kind of mentality i'm
like why would you deprive yourself of stuff i don't know
gosh things have changed so much i had fun meeting you at
the dentist and meet and greet i tried my best to get you to
get there since you replied to me on x aloud i feel like i
could barely say hello in the time allowed no Crops to
Mini-Nine.
The concert was also incredible.
Thank you!
I'm glad you could make it.
Hmm.
There's a lot of good stuff out there.
Right.
Why pit nerds against each other?
See what you mean.
Now I had a similar phase.
I think it was because also, like...
I don't know.
Back in the day, it felt like nerds were kind of like...
Against each other like the the comic the Western nerds and
the anime nerds like the Western media fans They were like
oh you like anime Our comics are superior
Nowadays everybody can be fans of everything.
It's great.
It's great It's my wife teal orca's birthday.
Could you sing for her?
Teal orca happy birthday Happy birthday to you Happy
birthday to you Happy birthday to your Lord God Happy
birthday to you Happy birthday Sort of like how console wars
were thing Right?
I'm glad that we've kind of moved past You know, lots of
things have changed And some for the worse But we have moved
past at least that aspect of stuff where the overarching
console wars and overarching nerd...
Nerd supremacy, whatever, whatever nonsense.
I'm glad at least that everybody can kind of just enjoy
whatever they want.
Sonic and Mario are friends now.
They ended it.
They ended the nerd war.
That's just because PC will...
Wait, I saw it.
Wait, the steam machine.
You can actually... Wait, is it only a pre-order?
Hold on.
I saw it on the steam store.
Steam... Steam store.
Is it only pre-order?
Out of stock.
Already?
Wait, yeah, it says join the wait list.
Wow.
Actually didn't, Jack.
for the VR headset.
I don't think I'll get the Steam Machine.
I don't need it.
But the headset or the VR headset as soon as it comes out,
that's a day one pre-order.
I feel like my VR headset, my Valve Index, has given me
enough problems that I need to get a new one.
Yeah.
So that one I will invest in.
The frame, the frame.
Yes, yes, yes.
actually quite excited for it so we'll see you'll see
brother my brother tell me what are we fighting for we've
got to end this war we should love one another
same if it's any good on price even if even if the steam
frame is very expensive it's it's It's an investment for me.
Because I really want to get back to doing VR stuff.
Oh, my gosh.
If you look at the Steam Machine.
If you look on the page, Metal Gear is right in the middle.
Whoa!
Right next to Silk Song and Portal 2.
And Dredge!
Oh, my gosh.
Snake!
He's right there!
No way they compare it.
They compare it.
the size of the steam machine to a banana.
They're trying to get you.
I've thought about, like, if I were to...
You know how, like, some VTubers have...
Or some streamers in general, they'll have, like, a
streaming machine, streaming computer, and then gaming
computer.
As a VTuber, I feel it would be very helpful because it's...
Because how hefty...
the vtuber everything can be yeah dual setup I was wondering
because it's so small too I was like what if but it's also
very expensive so I've considered it because the steam
machine is so small could be could be helpful yeah it's a
thousand plus dollars oh I'm very surprised so many VTubers
don't run a 2PC setup.
I'll be honest.
For me, it was like...
For the longest time, it was like...
This is going to sound so stupid.
It was an aesthetic thing.
But like, it was like...
I didn't want so many cords.
I already have so many cables that I have to manage.
And I just really...
My comparing computer is massive.
It's so big.
And I didn't have a good place to put a second PC...
So...
Yeah.
I don't know.
But more recently, I keep feeling like I want to have a
second PC set up.
Double the things to go wrong.
Right!
Technology and me don't mix.
The spaghetti monster is real.
So much cable, so much space.
Now you live in the jungle.
I do?
Oh.
Nah, what helped with gaming performance?
You could get a cheaper and smaller PC for that purpose.
Agreed.
Honestly, my travel PC might work even.
Just for...
Just for me.
Just for running my face.
Oh.
That's fine.
Let me test it with the portable setup.
I just thought of that just now.
I'll test it out on my next day off.
Whenever that is.
I'll test it on my next day off.
If I warm up.
I kind of like, though, the Steam Machine.
I'm looking at it again.
You can, like, customize the faceplate, which is cute.
Didn't Doki say that...
Like Faker or someone famous had a three PC set up.
Three?
Maybe three monitors.
Why would you need a three PC set up?
That's insane.
What's the third even four?
That's what I'm wondering.
What do you need the third one for?
Though I do have a second PC as a backup in case this one
dies for whatever reason.
Like I have a full, like it's with my old graphics card, but
it's still a pretty decent one.
So if, uh, if this ever goes, if this ever explodes for
whatever reason, I, I, I have my other one so that you guys
wouldn't be like, oh no, we'll never see her again.
Especially with like trying to get parts nowadays and new
things, yeah.
I barely have one.
Okay, to be fair though, it's my job.
So...
I could use that for your streaming PC, but it's very big.
It's very, it's very, it's another really, really big one.
I don't have any place.
I'm like looking around.
I don't have a place to set it up.
I would have to set up a teeny tiny one.
But hopefully, hopefully, May I...
May I...
Maybe Persians will go down with...
Fingies Christ.
I mean, that was awesome seeing you, Vicky and Phoebe live
on Legends of New.
I hope I won't have to wait long for the next concert.
Dr. Irrefutable.
Thank you so much.
I hope so too.
I am working on...
Well, how do I say...
Hmm...
It's not a full concert, but...
Things are...
Yeah, things are being worked on.
I mean...
It's already August!
Happy August, everybody!
Happy August!
Uh...
Oh...
My birthday is in Toon.
months from today.
My birthday is in two months from today.
Mm-hmm.
October 1st.
Time is flying for real.
Feels that way, right?
We're already in August.
Holy cow.
Ace Combat release.
Yeah!
It's like, what, isn't that like, October 2nd or something
the day after my birthday yeah I believe it's that Friday
yippee mine is September 29th so mine is close to will you
have to tell me again on September 29th yes yes yes yes yes
are you turning 20 why
would you ask there.
Maybe one of those dual motherboard cases if you can find
them or a PC that's stackable.
Holy cow.
Happy early birthday.
It was quite early.
I don't know.
Maybe.
I like my setup right now.
But having a second... I'll figure it out.
I can figure it out.
It's not for you guys to worry about.
I just want to have sailing streams you know no more frozen
models and and such such
i keep saying steam deck when i mean steam machine too many
steam steam things i i it's like oh there's so many idol or
no idol sorry so many vtuber centered events that have the
word ocean in them i my brain i'm like Like, oh she what
what oh she who oh she where oh she why what's the oh she
event that we're doing if please please if anybody in the
chat is wanting to make a vtuber event stop stop oh she hi
me so nice to meet you at the main cafe mean green the off
card thank you gold dragon Thank you to you and the rest of
Densits who were making my first concert and concert of
Unforgetable!
I'm so glad!
Thank you, thank you!
No shame.
17 is my lucky number slash my birthday was yesterday!
Hurry up and play my lovely nine.
What is in that?
Happy birthday Merker!
Thank you for the super chat.
Happy, happy birthday!
Mods, more Oshi.
More!
more more oh my gosh that reminds me of when uh at disney
with vicky we went on rise of the resistance which is like
one of my favorite rides it's a star wars ride but there's
lots of stone there's lots of story troopers out here
and chila i really like the stormtroopers and vicky really
likes kyle ren so together we were just like
I would be like no don't interrogate me if you want answers
from me you're gonna have to use a lot of floors no
because if you ever go on that ride the the staff that that
like manage it the Disney staff they are they're why
stormtroopers isn't a mask thing stop calling me
if you if you ever are nice to them if you like say thank
you and stop
they'll like insult you I want One time, one time, they were
like, they were like, put your least favorite people in the
front of the ride.
And then they looked at me and they were like, we can see
why you're in the front.
My birthday was last Tuesday.
Hungry board, happy birthday.
I am now officially unc status.
Still have no idea what I'm doing or what anything means.
That's okay.
I don't think anybody knows.
cute ghost minutes to distract me from my existential crisis
happy birthday they did they really called you out like that
they did it's so funny call you Darth Simpius don't call me
that but um very fun me I want to judge you but I'm no
better you are all no better better than me.
You are no better than me.
Charge our minks.
Did Vicky really call out to Kylo Ren?
Oh yeah.
Actually, it was my first time ever seeing, luckily there
were no stormtroopers walking around, but it was my first
time ever seeing, uh, characters walking around in this, in
the Star Wars area.
And I got to, we got to meet Ray.
She was so nice.
Um, We dunked on Steiner, and she was like, dang, they're
just dragging you.
She was like, she was like, what have you done for them to
hate you so much?
And then I also got to meet the Mandalorian and Grogu, baby
Yoda.
It's a log story.
I think they know.
She doesn't know.
Baby Yoda.
Yeah, he was so cute.
He was so cute.
I laughed when an officer was giving us instructions.
He came up to me and said, Do we laugh when we're nervous?
And she would not stop staring.
That's so awesome.
As a pit crew, we were so excited for Ashton to torture
Steiner.
Yes, yes, yes.
Ashton joined the Satsuna.
um very awesome for anybody who is a pit crew kind of
confused about what's going on with that um basically like
it's very it's kind of similar with like densa too we're
still indie but she just got a manager but rather than
rather than them being like a random person they're just
with the company so um yeah so kind of just similar to us
where we're we're still indie we just have managers they're
just their own group remember Ayavu's whatever you think
Steiner did to deserve it deserve this it was worse
absolutely right basically indie but with more back end
support exactly exactly exactly exactly yeah so I'm very
excited because Ashton is an extremely creative individual I
love her stuff so I'm very excited to see what kind of
project she dies and with some proper backing how they can
help her out with that and stuff so yeah yeah cool cool cool
how do vtubers find managers the thing is is I don't even
know I don't even know which is why I kept trying to join
companies I feel finding a my work ethic is like very
demanding I fear and so I need someone that is on my same
work ethical level really just depends on what you're kind
of looking for I'd love to know your Star Wars designs
opinions maybe after you watch the movies yeah kind of
opinions you want the creative versus business minds yes I
am not so good with the business minds.
I do not know so much about the business.
I am probably I I fear I am well, I don't know.
I'm not so good with that stuff.
That stuff scares me.
I just want to be a silly girl.
I don't want to think about anything.
You found three other workaholics to hang out with.
Ah, yeah.
Yeah!
Same, I just want to be silly.
Only silly, only silly.
I don't want to be, I don't want to say the hard things.
But sometimes I feel like I have to.
You know, obviously I have a manager.
Sometimes I have to be the...
We're not the bad guy.
I'm the bad guy.
Meow.
Do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do.
No, sometimes I feel like, you know, I fear it must be a
little bit more.
put my my ghostly foot down sometimes we got a lock in yeah
comes
with the territory sometimes what a gosh we're playing a
game today everybody welcome back to water park sit why am I
lagging oh my gosh This literally goes back to what I was
just talking about with the PC!
Why am I lagging?
I don't think any settings got changed unless...
Oh, wait.
Whoa, whoa.
Whoa, there's so many.
Wait, um...
Maybe I should lower the resolution.
Is it this one?
Wait.
What?
What's the difference?
Wait, is there F...
Oh, FPS limit.
Me, that'll help.
Sorry, I haven't opened this game in so long, and it
updated, so I think it changed a bunch of stuff.
Ha-da!
So to change the topic then, yesterday with Ayami-sensei,
you were talking about some sort of toggle for this outfit.
Could you elaborate?
There.
Forgetty Beam!
Wait, where'd it go?
There.
What's the difference between these two?
There is none.
There's no difference.
They both say 60.
Wait.
Am I crazy?
I'm just gonna pick it.
Sorry, I'm gonna have to resize afterwards.
Dip.
Oh, actually nothing changed.
But I'm smoother.
I said, one does vertical refresh and one does...
Doesn't, who knows, but it fixed.
There is no naked toggle in by Shinsuke.
Holy moly, two years until months.
That's so, thank you!
Thank you!
That's a crazy amount.
How raw!
Thank you so much for the part, Gifton.
Apparently, this game got a huge update.
I guess it's now out of early access.
Like, the full update.
Full version has been released.
so I wanted to try playing it again I'm always down for a
good simulator game so they added more water yeah more water
I think it's got its 1.0 update yeah I think so I think so
yeah I love a good I love a good simulator game something
about them are just so cozy i like the aztec temple thing i
guess there's like the look at this new feature cleanliness
management multiplayer character editor beach beach beach
aztec ocean mafia
thematic attractions marriage complete got married last
Saturday we got married last Saturday congratulations
congratulations but we have our game let me see if I
continue Zanzibar land almost an entire year ago wait wait
Almost an entire year ago since I last played.
That's craziness.
Holy cow.
Wait, that doesn't even feel that long.
Time flies so fast.
What?
The union is starting to save for the patch.
Honestly, I didn't look into it.
Let's just continue my game and see what's going on.
What's going down in here.
New adventure awaits!
The museum has just opened its doors.
Bringing new adventures to your park.
Meet unique characters, complete quests, and earn special
resources as rewards.
Unlock exclusive attractions and work your way towards a
legendary one-direction.
I think I'm outside my place.
It's been a minute since I last played- Oh, the museum here!
Whoa, oh.
I could just talk to him.
Oh, I could just walk in here.
The attractions are not off- Laura Croft?
Wait.
Hello?
I've discovered something intriguing among ruins.
It may be- it may take a bit of effort to uncover the full
story.
But the reward could be well worth it.
Interested?
Yeah.
ancient symbols.
Boo.
Not every mark on a wall deserves scholarly attention.
Dang, let's remove a few of them.
Dang, she called your words useless.
I like the whales.
They're very cute.
What kind of museum is this anyway?
Ah!
Oh, puppy.
We're removing what one now?
Pick up visitor.
What are you doing?
Oh, my God.
He's on my shoulders.
Wait.
What am I doing to this bed?
What do I do with you?
How do I put you down?
Oh.
Sorry, Ezra.
So this is how we turn...
night shift and
what is this 484 dollars overtime payment look at my park
it's looking pretty spiffy I'd say you're extracting him and
then we have this whole area oh my gosh I have to remember
how to play this game I have to remember how to wait so what
am I doing with Clara loft let's let's repair these
Kinda not...
Oh.
Gosh.
Who are you?
When did I hire this guy?
Catch and release.
We're repairing everything.
I do remember I need to do this quite frequently.
Cleaning and fixing mostly.
Yes, yes.
Clearly we just got this new area, so we have not touched it
in quite literally a year.
and get out of the way get out of the way i'm hammering here
victor why do you have a taser because some people are bad
you may be you may be a young fresh-eyed sparkly sparkly
outlook on the world but some people they're bad and they
will And they must be punished.
Actually, I didn't even realize.
When did I get a taser?
Victor, I have a new job for you.
Where'd you go?
Victor?
Oh, Victor!
Dang.
Victor, come here.
Taskless.
Purify the walls.
Clean graffiti from vandals.
Oh, that's part of our Laura Croft quest.
It's Ames.
Use the printer to print out flyers and give them to
pedestrians.
And we gotta open the park.
Hold on, we will once I've repaired everything.
Everything, everything needs repairing right now.
We're at three stars.
Our place is really cute though, no?
You guys like it?
Can you stick the taser in the pool?
I'll do it myself.
I'm okay.
we we lived we're so strong and awesome so if I click build
I think we can like deconstruct these things no uh okay hold
on I know there's a way to deconstruct this I can't fix it
good thing I'm already dead exactly oof good thing wow look
Look how much stuff there is now.
Whoa, wee.
Pizza?
Small water blob.
Can you fix me?
No, there's no way.
Yeah, these...
These types of things.
Oh, the sledgehammer!
Maybe I can get rid of it with the sledgehammer.
Oh, oh.
Note to self.
I can't even swim.
There should be a sledgehammer around here somewhere.
Uh.
What is this?
Take floor tool.
Oh, that must be for like...
For,
uh...
What's the word?
It's like making this area look nice.
It's hammer time.
Destroy the trash.
Destroy it all.
Destroy the building with my own two hands.
Yes, yes.
Destroy building.
It's a rage room.
Give me something to break!
How about this freaking bush?
Hope you know I pack a sledgehammer.
Yeah, I am super strong.
Watch it.
Clean the paper!
Remove the bush!
Destroy trash!
Clean paper.
I just growl at it and it disappears.
Ah!
Watch this, watch this.
Terrifying.
We're already at like fourth star though.
We will be getting the big stuff soon.
And let's see.
Hold on.
I'm trying to, like, jump on this to, like...
We should be getting that area, probably.
Those look residential, but I'm okay with tearing them down.
Dragonborn Minto.
Minto da!
Fusro da!
Da!
Minto da!
Yeah, causing a little bit of a housing crisis.
But it would be...
Okay, which would you rather have?
Houses or a sick water park?
Don't tear down my apartment just for a hot dog stand.
But would you rather have a place to live or a delicious
dog?
Be honest with yourself.
Water park and a house.
that one like that one house that was oh wait I can destroy
these two do we not want these as well it's that house that
was it's like a it's like a cold world cold cold world
bunker cold war bunker but they made it an entire house
underneath the ground with a backyard and everything it's
got like a hot pool and at least they can go down the slide
I'm homeless no cold world bunker no no it's like yeah I
think it's in Vegas yeah it's very it's like so strange I
guess we're destroying these two I guess we don't like them
also or oh we can make them look nicer.
See, this is one that's placed.
Actually, I don't know anymore.
Are some of these placed with intention?
Maybe not.
Wait, this one didn't get repaired.
Nice.
Do these need to be repaired?
Oh my gosh, everything needs repairing.
Causing a house crisis?
House, house, house, housing, house.
Housing crisis?
She really is a boomer.
Yeah!
This is for me, but not for thee.
Thy get water parks!
Yeah!
Eating some minto ice cream.
Yummy!
It's a water slide and a mini shower two in one.
I'm just so innovative like that.
Okay, now I think I actually got everything.
Now everything seems actually...
Oh!
I'm a liar.
Okay, now I think I actually got everything.
Double water slide.
So fancy.
After the end of warm, warm war, too.
The world was split into two.
Weast and schmist.
This marked the beginning of the period called the Cold War.
War, world.
Oh, right now we're in warm, warm, warm.
world three because it it do be high out here okay um i have
1400 i don't remember what i was trying to build before so
let's build some sick stuff we can do hot tubs and stuff
eventually do we have like a big slide
halloween i have nothing how do i unlock stuff I'm almost
four stars four star park but I have nothing unlocked hmm
maybe it's fine right now we got a good amount of stuff so
you can unlock more stuff at the tool shed is that how it
works ah oh popcorn stand
Duck-shaped turret that sprays water, I guess.
Very, very interesting.
Night shift.
Maintenance decorations.
Oh!
This is $300.
Okay, I think we gotta save up for more stuff.
We gotta save up for stuff.
Alright, Braylon.
Braylon, I'm counting on you.
Open the park, baby.
to open park on beach map uh sure there you go you two
everybody come already wants a ticket oh just kidding
already wants a ticket roland roland roland you gotta come
to my park come on yes yes molly molly already wants to come
everybody's here for the theme I don't have time for you.
I don't have time for you.
Oh, sorry.
You want to go to park?
Use the printer to print out flyers and give them to
pedestrians.
But it still says...
Wait.
I haven't been giving them out!
I was like, why am I still at zero?
Yeah, very cool.
Very cool.
everybody here is legally here.
What the?
Braylon?
Braylon, why are you sleeping on the job?
Buddy.
Oh, shoot.
I'll be back.
Braylon!
Oh.
Are they leaving?
I'm so sorry.
I didn't mean it.
I'm a monster.
I'm a monster who Just tackles through people.
No, come here.
Yeah, come here.
Hey, hey, hey.
It's not that I'm violent.
I'm just, you know.
I'm like Frankenstein.
I don't know my own strength.
Jeffrey, Jeffrey, Jeffrey.
Oh, she is a scholar.
Talk about aggressive advertising.
Oh.
Did somebody just die?
Guests waited too long for lemonade!
Oh no, that's right!
I have to be, like, working the place!
Oh my gosh, who did that?
Hello?
Uh, yes.
What do you want?
Victoria?
Uh, you want lemonade?
You want lemonade?
Does it say what she wants?
I gave her an empty cup.
Who did this?
I can't read.
I couldn't see where it was written.
Oh, I need my gun.
Not to shoot.
To clean.
Love that.
Splash.
Ew, you can really smell the chlorine here.
It's kind of terrible.
What's wrong, Kiana?
What's wrong?
It's a floating text above the jug.
Again.
It's been a year since I've uh blade restock snacks vending
machine oh my bad requires mop oh there's graffiti on here
did i get it how do i restock you i restock it currently
enjoying the lemonade and my minto gamer subs bug thank you
why are you why are you evil wait Why are you evil?
Oh, restock required here.
Requires mop.
Oh.
I just peed, I think, is what it said.
Oh, we gotta go to the store!
That's right!
Sorry.
So sorry.
Why is it so dusty out here?
Let's go to the store.
Uh-oh.
Guess waited too long for lemonade!
Um...
Uh-oh.
Granola.
I'm losing.
I'm losing all these customers.
No, I'm not.
I've made so much money.
Okay.
Lemonade.
I got this.
No.
Hot dog.
Add ketchup.
Yeah!
Oh, I forgot.
I gotta get more hot dogs.
Maybe that's why they're mad.
Maybe.
Oh.
So sorry.
Please don't sue me.
They're fine.
They're having a great time.
You want to come?
Oh, no.
Then don't talk to me.
Why is everybody a scientist?
Yeah.
We gotta glizzy it up.
That dog was a year old.
Could be.
Could...
Oh, no.
Oh, no, no, no.
Yes, what do you want?
I want lemonade.
Add ice.
Yes?
I want lemonade.
Oh, there!
No!
There is definitely some, sir.
Don't go anywhere.
Stinky trash.
Wait!
Oh.
Oh, there we go.
We're fine.
Welcome to Kmart.
lemons and life give you lemons somebody is drowning hold on
i gotta restock this up
peeing turning the phone off for the theater but have a fun
time boss have a fun time with the movie thanks for super
chat now i remember how stressful this is we too we too some
guests might relieve themselves right in the water make it
get dirty for everyone You'll spot them by the yellow trail
in the water.
A well-timed push will remind them of the rules.
Yes, ma'am.
Add ketchup.
Oh.
Not ma'am.
Sorry.
I want lemonade.
Add lemon.
There you go.
Oh, sorry.
Are you drowning or...
There you go.
I owe you one.
Yes, you do.
You owe me 50 bucks for that.
This guy's just drowning.
You can handle it.
Who's peeing now?
Who's peeing in the water?
Who do I need to push?
Why is it so like hazy outside?
I want lemonade out of ice.
Yep, you're welcome.
My life garden.
Victoria!
Vicky!
I don't think anybody's peeing.
Everybody's jumping out backwards.
It's kind of sick.
Wait, can I grab that?
Yeah.
Oh, someone else is drowning.
Why are you guys going to the pool if you don't know how to
swim?
Hello.
Lemonade?
Add lemon.
Yep.
I wonder if I could put these back on here.
Oh, what is this?
I picked up science!
What the hell is that?
Lemonade out of ice!
$20 lemonade is crazy, you guys.
Lemonade out of lemon.
Craziness!
Victor is too tired and going to rest.
Victor, no, I need to.
Are you having a good time?
Looks like a colon.
Looks like Edward colon.
Wired and ready.
Why'd you say that when I got on top of you?
I don't like that.
I don't think I'm a fan of that.
Okay.
All right.
What?
Why?
Thumbs down?
Harmony, please.
Let's talk about this.
We can talk about this.
Please,
please!
Excigioso!
No.
Did I collect the graffiti?
Oh, I did it!
Thank you, the only markings left are the important ones.
Okay, we did it?
Uh-huh.
I've discovered something intriguing among ruins.
It may take a bit of effort to uncover the full story.
Yeah?
It's hard to uncover the mysteries of the past when half the
site is trying to become a pond.
Let's see if we can reclaim a little dry land.
Mop up puddles.
Oh, someone's drowning.
But what if?
What if you wanted to go to the park instead?
Sorry.
Why are you guys...
Oh.
Sometimes guests may throw up.
No guest sickness mode removes related visual and audio
effects.
Oh.
Do you guys want to hear?
Clara loft.
Oh, did I say Laura?
Sorry, I'm getting A totally different person.
Mint, I screwed up.
If it's bad.
If it's...
If it's bad, we'll just...
We'll get rid of it for sure.
But it could be fine.
Trying to get the 15 out of 20.
You know?
Sorry.
Tony.
Oh, sorry, we got someone drowning.
Uh, hello.
No, no!
I need to tase this person.
Hold on.
Clean water isn't forever.
The park has grown and the filters can't keep up the crowds.
Wait, how did I receive a fine?
From who?
Who's drowning?
Are we fine?
Oh.
Chelsea!
Take my life from...
Oh.
Oh, shoot.
Wait.
Where'd my gun go?
Yes?
Lemonade?
Add ice.
Uh-huh.
Yep.
Lemonade?
Easy.
Simple customer.
Lemonade add ice.
This is your second lemonade today, buddy.
Yeah.
So true.
My teeth to clean up the stinky.
Not again!
Oh my god.
Oh, we cleaned!
Oh.
Did we...
Oh, what's happening here?
What's...
We have an evil cloud hovering over us, everybody?
What's going on?
Too dirty!
Oh my god.
Unplugged the drain?
Wait, how are my...
I don't think they're that...
They look blue to me.
Oh.
Bye, Chelsea.
Oh, this one looks kind of gross.
Okay, uh, oh, we're dying.
We did it.
Someone is peeing in the pool.
Oh, there's a poop.
Oh, man.
Wait, no.
I don't want that.
Clean up the poop.
All right.
All right, go home, everybody.
Go home.
Good job, team.
Now it's the quietest time of the day.
Oh.
Is this 132?
We'll just unplug everything.
All this water is a year old.
That's a little stressful, huh?
Nobody has manners anymore.
Victor is literally standing in the trash can.
He can't do this anymore.
He can't do this anymore!
Alright, um, I wonder if I can still hand out these flyers.
Pizza.
I don't think anybody's around.
You seek balance, young splash maker.
Enlightenment isn't found, it's cleaned up.
Don't overthink it, just grab the trash and call it a
metaphor.
Oh, clear trash by yourself.
There's so many, like, tasks now.
you need to oh i need to i need to open the park to poach
people i had a much kinder way of thinking about it but sure
okay here's my sledgehammer which i don't need right now
wait oh okay oh there's second gun okay cool yeah we're
poaching them we're poaching them let's go grab some snacks
let's go fill up for tomorrow Tomorrow will be a better day.
That's not what I meant to grab.
We made a ton of money, though.
Maybe it's better to activate all tasks.
This way it's easier to complete.
Yeah, I'm thinking that too, right?
Okay.
Honestly, I'll just keep the hot dogs behind the table.
I think there's one more pool.
We got this, guys.
We've got this.
Grab my hot dogs.
And we'll grab some more lemons for the lemonade.
I won't refill the lemonade until it's like empty empty.
Because I don't want to waste it.
Welcome to Kmart.
What else can we grab here?
What is that?
Hello, mister.
What's this?
Unlocked.
Duck gun 20,000.
Wait, there is Saba!
Oh my gosh!
Saba's in the game!
So cute!
I never knew that she was actually in the game.
So funny.
I always saw people being like, there's a Saba something.
But I didn't know she was actually around.
That's so awesome.
Alright, let's fix everything up.
Clean it all.
Does this need to be cleaned?
Oh, it does.
Oh, geez.
There's so much to do.
Cleaning and repairing and doing it all by myself.
Oh, running a park is so hard.
Oh, my.
Yeah, so many Maidly duties.
Sometimes it, do you guys see the screen tearing or is it
just me?
I don't see it in OBS, so it might just be me.
But if so, it's good.
Where's Ryan when you need him?
Ryan!
Oh, okay, this is a brown!
I was wondering if it was just dirty, but it is a brown, it
is a brown slide.
You don't see it?
Okay, it's on my end.
I don't mind it, if it's on my end.
the fact you have to repair everything and also clean it too
much work too much work okay all right let's clean this i
need a full i need a full staff here
i think you need to pick up your employee he needs to pick
up the slack that's what he needs
Oh, clean, clean, clean, repair, repair, repair, all with my
own two hands.
Oh, now we have $4,000, almost $5,000.
We're rolling in dough, baby.
Yes, it's a maid mint, not repair man mint.
Hire me, me too, I'll work hard.
Bane, you work for two.
cents an hour how you feel about that stronger hands
inflatable vending machine a jukebox wait what's stronger oh
i get to push things more small water blob um popcorn stand
we could do the spray can duck turret almost even more paint
mascot staff higher mascots wait more decorations okay let's
do snacks now reach guests before they get grumpy okay wait
some of these are really good staff helps clean fix in the
morning before the park opens so you don't have to do it all
by yourself Oh, you know, that's so true.
He was doing it in the morning, wasn't he?
That's okay, though.
I think going for the park decoration and the vendor
training is good, and then we could save for the mascot
staff.
Oh, but I kind of want the mascot staff.
But I think we can only have so many people working for me
at a time.
Not quite... I don't quite remember how to hire people.
Medkit injector.
Call building company.
Oh, neat.
Yeah, I need the big stuff.
I have like nothing.
Let's get more...
Let's do... let's do what I was gonna do.
Which was the uh...
Not maintenance, but what is there?
Night shift.
Maintenance decoration.
Let's get this.
Let's get more park decoration.
Wait, how much for more attractions?
Zipline Tower!
Resort pools.
Oh.
I should...
I should save up for this.
I should save up for the resort pools.
We want the big stuff.
Lifeguard staff.
Bigger tab.
Modern slides!
Wait.
Adds budget friendly slides that are quick to set up and
easy to enjoy.
We want more slides, right?
We want more bigger things.
But I also want more decorations.
Okay, I will buy this because it's just cash.
And not like the research points.
And then we'll save for some of these things.
other thing.
Yep, thank you.
Is this the water park that, by the, of the, uh, the water
park, uh, run by the really cute girl?
Do you think I could get her contact info?
You know, for investment purposes?
I need big slides.
I need investors for slides.
If you were on Twitch chat, could visit the park or be hired
so you could get mad at us.
Really wish YouTube chat could do that too.
Wait, that's so fun i wish youtube chat could do that too
yeah
that sounds so fun there's so many cool things that like
twitch integration is good about all right well what did i i
bought the uh oops um some of the decoration stuff let's see
what we got oh wait decorations here we go
wait is this one what's one of those fountains i don't think
i have one of these Can I move my camera around?
How do I rotate?
No, not the building.
I want to rotate myself.
These are like one of those, one of those, like...
Here, we'll just...
I'll just put it right there.
What else we got?
We got balloons.
Cherry blossoms.
Oh my god.
Suboi.
Wait, don't these go in the water?
Wait, did I mess up?
I'll put it in here.
We gotta go build it.
Oh, yeah.
We don't have anything like that in here.
Perfect.
Nice.
Waterpark Japan.
I've only been to one waterpark in Japan.
I think.
Nice throw.
eight out of ten yeah I guess we'll just uh hold out for now
whoa where to go oh there it is like the best throw ever no
there's a there's a place in Nagoya called Nagashima spa
land wait but I don't I'm thinking I don't think I went to
the water park part of it.
I think I only went to the, uh...
Are these gnomes?
Aw, I remember being able to climb up this before.
Maybe you still can.
I don't think I went to the water park.
I think it's like a theme park slash water park slash uh...
Slash...
Spaw.
So it's pretty fancy.
Alright, let's go to sleep.
I need to figure out how to hire more people.
I don't quite actually remember.
Hey, Braylon.
How we doing?
Maybe.
Oh, here.
Higher.
Oh, I can get another person.
I can, I can, I can.
Let's get Abraham.
For being our vendor.
I think we should have somebody as a vendor.
Wait.
95% efficiency 167% efficiency their movement speed is slow
but they're like kind of a lot better Declan wait
what's the number oh
Nagashima Spanlan was super fun the big steel dragon 2000
was a good time isn't it so fun isn't it so fine yeah maybe
we'll get but Declan is also least less expensive.
We're hiring them.
We need somebody as a... Oh, it's raining.
Are we gonna have less people coming today, though?
Not assigned.
What do you mean that I assigned you to be a vendor?
Where are you?
Oh, wait.
Manage.
You are assigned to the vending...
Where are you?
You, you, you.
Wait, come here.
Come here.
Come here, buddy.
No, where are you going?
What the?
Come here.
You go.
Thank you so much, brother.
Thank you so much for the...
Thank you.
Right here.
How do I assign you?
Go to the stand and click on nameplate.
Oh, thank you so much.
Oh, no.
Okay.
He's only...
Yeah, yeah.
He's only on, uh...
Um...
On Lemonade.
But this is fine, probably.
Alright, let's open up!
You wanna go!
Yeah, you wanna go!
You- Oh!
Oh!
My flyers!
Uh...
Oh.
You wanna go.
More unique guests.
You've met someone troublesome before, but not every unusual
guest is a problem.
Somebody doesn't actually help you out, keep your eyes open.
Yeah, we got this.
We got Isekide for real.
Don't worry about it.
What about you?
Best day ever, that's what I'm saying.
Yeah, you too.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
What about you?
We just need...
We'll collect research points from smart guy.
Oops, I'm stuck on now.
Alright.
Let me grab my mop and stuff.
You just got hit by car time.
Yeah, come to the water park.
Don't think about your water.
Don't think about your worries.
La la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la la
la la la la.
So far so good.
You're getting a snack, huh?
Yeah.
Good job, Victoria.
Oh, graffiti.
After comparing my current salary with my new potential
salary of 4160, I decided to quit my job and apply to your
water park.
Welcome to the team, buddy!
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, uh, pineapple!
Welcome to membership.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
Jasmine, are you going to give me good points?
Someone was...
Oh, wait, I thought there was a graffiti there.
Yes, nice and sparkly clean.
How do I say your name?
Oh, stinko, stinko, stinko alert.
Stinko alert.
Oh, not you.
oh my god that's not very some of these people are not safe
at all thanks so much for playing from the dev team oh thank
you thanks for the fun game yeah thank you thank you thanks
for the super chat
oh please give me points give me points journey come on
you're having an amazing time right now you're having the
best time I'll give you more lemons.
Dogs are fine.
Dogs are out.
Come on, journey.
Come on.
Give me all the points you've got.
So far, everything is pretty.
Smooth.
Oh, trash.
sorry wait five out of ten throw come okay it could have
been better oh I'll admit that one could have been better oh
what was I getting oh granola one thing that I have a hard
time doing is getting the puddles I'm struggling with get oh
oh my own puddle no no no no no it's me It's me!
Sorry, Victor.
It's all me.
Let me mop up the puddle.
He didn't mind it at all.
In fact, he thanked me afterwards.
Oh, nice, nice.
I need to clean up...
How many?
I need to clean up 15 of them.
He didn't mind it at all.
So many scholars, so many smart people in my park.
Anybody waiting on a hot dog?
No hot dog enjoyers today?
Wait, I see a research point.
Somebody just dropped it on the ground.
Mine.
Oh, there's two more.
There's two more.
Yes.
Braylon got too tired.
Okay, we got to take over for Braylon's job, guys.
I have to remember how to do this.
$20 lemonade.
Yeah, only the smartest people come here.
Mm-hmm.
Oh.
Hello.
Welcome to the park.
Pass for six hours.
You're a teen.
Slide pass.
Dozo.
It's $26 to get in here and about the same price for a...
for a thing of lemonade what the I think we had a criminal
criminal scum on the loose oh we might have had a criminal
scum on the loose more research wait this is huge this is
huge nobody wants hot dogs today a smooth criminal you've
been hit by you've been struck by me
Uh-oh.
Oh, I got this!
Please, please, please.
Let me handle it.
Let the professional handle it.
Yeah, refreshing!
Don't think about it.
You don't even know.
You don't even know that you just fell and got a concussion.
You have no idea.
Braylon, I need you to get back to work, buddy.
You think I pay you to eat pizza?
So much science around.
to be able to unlock so much stuff.
I forgot that people have to pay to use the...
To swim.
They have to pay to swim.
They have to pay to shower.
They have to pay to literally anything.
It's so funny.
Oh.
Victoria!
Teen.
Slide patch.
Actual scam.
We are running a shrewd business, that's for sure.
Don't...
Oh, are you stinky or...
Wait, no, let me get it.
New buildings available!
I don't...
Oops.
Oh.
Oh, man.
Wait.
Oh.
Did I mess up?
Oh, I messed that up.
Oh.
Victor, get out of the trash can!
Come on, man.
You were embarrassing me, please!
At least the super chats are free.
Says who?
This is no apple surf.
Oh, I think we have to...
Oh, sorry!
Imagine you're like swimming in the pool and they just like
drain it in front of you.
Well, thank you so much for the- What?
Says Vicky.
Victoria Romana is swimming in my pool at this very moment.
Can we get some Phoebe's here as well?
Wait, what's this?
Wait, how the hell?
I heard the super chats are free.
They are not!
I'm running a shrewd business please!
Nothing in my park is free!
You have to pay to breathe!
Oh, oops.
Oh my gosh.
Oh, wow.
We look.
Guys, don't look.
Don't look at me.
Oh, uh-oh.
Uh-oh.
I'll pick up the trash.
I saw another puddle here.
Yeah.
I got a mop up.
We got 8 out of 15.
Thank you guys for the super chat.
It's free super chat day.
No.
We got the same deal as Vicky.
No, I'm running a really, I'm running a shrewd business, you
guys.
Nothing can be free.
It can't be free.
I need you to pay money.
Pay up, pay up.
Pay up, Jeffrey.
Is Jasmine okay?
Oh my gosh, thank you guys.
My lemonade stand needs to be restocked.
I'm on it.
I have no time to look both ways.
I think people are just entering my park for free,
unfortunately.
Oh yes, hello.
What would you like?
Add ketchup.
Oh my gosh, pay up!
Well, if you say so!
No!
I mean...
But...
You guys...
paying that means you are enjoying all the amenities of my
park oh my gosh thank you guys okay boss no i didn't mean it
oh gosh i'm sorry i didn't mean it what is that ew it's
vomit ew that's actually terrible oh sorry
Yes, ma'am.
Ow!
Do you know there's a color slider for these free Supas?
No, this is how I feel!
Stop it!
Declan is too tired and going to rest.
Oh my gosh.
Hello.
I want lemonade.
Yeah, and I want your business.
Oh my gosh.
Ah!
Oh my god.
Wait, where's my trash cans?
Wait, where's my trash bags?
I'm out of trash bags!
Oh no!
Take a vision for the park!
You got it!
That's not!
That's not it!
Get back to Yogi.
We're getting so much science.
Oh, thank goodness.
Decoration needs improvement!
Uh-oh, oh my gosh!
A supreme!
Thank you for the pink!
The color sliders look amazing, especially since they are
free!
No!
My business!
Nothing can be free!
Does this count?
Okay, good.
This does count as mopping up puddles.
And then we get the temple.
Oh wow, there's so many to mop up.
Holy cow.
Holy... Oh wait, that's vomit.
terrible.
Okay, we gotta get back to Chloro Loft and Yogi.
When did I buy this?
Thank me, thank you!
Limp and beam!
I slipped while running and me head now.
This color is everywhere.
Is that bad?
Uh, we did not cover ambulance fees.
Sorry.
Here's my daily super chat.
Even I miss Zach.
I miss York.
No.
Oh, thank
God.
One hot dog and one complimentary free super.
In the bag, in the bag, in the bag.
Free super is in this economy.
No, my business, please.
I can't give anything.
You want to, you got...
Oh, oh, oh.
If you want to even use this...
this see I didn't pay and that's what happens if you don't
pay up if you don't pay up that's what's gonna happen
nothing is free let's just go to sleep oh my goodness they
use the heck out of this oh wait no we were gonna go talk to
people let's go talk to yogi and stuff is it free to get
sprayed with the water gun Okay, that is free.
Requires what?
Poster.
Oh.
Wait, huh?
You must let the water dance.
Give it shape.
Give it purpose.
Let your park reflect the chaos within you.
I have to build more fountains.
The ruins are ready to be explored again.
Yes, yes, I'm interested.
I've got paints prepared for traditional ceremony.
Now I just need a few willing participants.
Saga!
now I sold my house to pay for the super were you living in
a box more
fountains and paint get what do you mean paint guests what
does that mean like with this I just painted something I
don't even know what color I'm doing it's like
I did get a thing saying the decorations were lacking.
So we'll paint a little bit.
Get the decorations going.
Ooh, it's all shiny now.
Yes.
Gold?
Yeah.
It's my kingdom.
Here, let's go to sleep.
So that we can...
Everybody will work in the morning.
Is it still raining?
Nobody's gonna come.
We gotta make this look like a fancy park.
Oh my gosh.
Look, we can even do the outside and everything.
Can I do these?
No.
Um...
Change color.
Here we go.
Oh!
What's this?
Let's do like a bright blue.
Like this.
Let's see how this looks.
Oh, that's fine.
It's better than before, right?
Yes.
You hear that mint?
That's the sound of free soupers.
I don't hear anything.
I...
I refuse.
We can paint these too, even.
I want, like...
Oh, let's do yeah.
Ooh.
Boy, yeah.
Wait, I want, like, a bright red.
Oh, this is, like, so summery, no?
It looks like...
It looks like a popsicle.
It looks delicious.
It looks good.
Oh, oh.
Oops.
I have to repaint that.
It's okay.
It's $5.
We'll get it back, I think.
Popsicle, yeah.
Popsicle.
Oh.
I can't even paint these, I think.
What if I do yellow?
Wow!
Wow, look at that.
What are the different materials?
What's this one?
Oh, it actually makes it look different.
Let's go back to this.
Oh, wait.
Is this not the right color that I had before?
It looks a little different.
Am I crazy?
No, I did it wrong again.
Why is this one different?
It's the lighting?
There's a distinct line, though.
Here, too!
Huh?
Oh my gosh, our place is looking so spiffy now.
Looks so fancy.
You should come to the water park.
So blue.
Yeah.
Don't you know it?
I mean, it's a water park.
When you think of water park, what are we thinking of?
Blue.
Blue, everything.
Dabadi.
That song was actually about a water park.
Dabadi, dabadi.
Almost missed free supas.
Well, the park's not open yet.
You will be paying for that.
Let's do a super blue.
Oh, yeah!
Wait, this is looking so good!
What do you guys think?
So far.
Looks good?
Now they won't be able to complain.
They won't be able to complain.
Where's my guy to do repairs?
Oh, he's...
You know, a little slow.
Looks good.
You really think so?
This is where your super chats are being...
This is where they are going.
Invested back into my small business.
You are supporting.
Got beef.
Mama's on it.
Too early.
you're missing something.
Who am I missing?
What am I missing?
Wait, what does that mean?
I'm frightened.
Who's mama?
Why is she on my...
Help, I'm scared.
Oh, I'm in this vestige.
Oh, thank you.
I didn't mean to do
that.
I wish that it wasn't so easy to, like, accidentally do a
part because you have to pay five dollars every time
our place is looking really spiffy I don't know what I want
to do with the roof yet minus 10 bucks oh no I did it here
too oh actually that was fine that was fine yeah that one's
fine
yellow roof Hello roof.
Or?
What?
What is this tile?
There's so many colors we don't have.
I think yellow might be good.
What if a yellow brick?
It looks terrible.
Oh yeah.
White?
We could try white.
Looks like mustard.
Yeah, this is...
No!
You jerk!
It's tough.
I think white is too bland.
I think, uh, I think yellow looks... I already did white
though on everything.
It's so actually we can do some white, some yellow.
Whoa.
Some white, some yellow.
It's energy efficient.
Look how much money we've already spent.
We've spent so much money painting our place.
I should go spend some of our research stuff.
Let's see.
What do we got?
We got 11 points.
I know I wanted resort pools.
So we'll do that.
Power throw.
Okay.
And we'll do maybe the popcorn stand.
Even more paint colors.
Vendor training too.
Mascot staff.
Can I even hire that though?
I wonder.
Basic drink vending machine.
Maintenance.
Chlorine.
Trash highlight.
Resort showers.
Resort toilets.
The jukebox?
Wait, so then we could get the modern slides and stuff?
Water gun upgrade.
Security.
It allows you to hire.
But we can't hire any more people.
That's my thing.
Because even if I hire a mascot or do the mascot staff, I'm
like, can I even hire them?
I would have to fire somebody else.
I think.
But I want it.
Oh!
Where's my trash can?
Where's my trash bags?
I want Julie.
I want Julie to be my mascot.
I was right, though.
I think having...
Hmm.
I have a dumpster.
Trash bags are at the dumpster?
They are?
Oh, right here.
I have to pay.
Even I have to pay for everything.
It's insane.
Do you only clean?
Do you not repair stuff?
Goodness.
Hmm.
I think he cleaned everything though.
Why is part of my...
Why is...
What was I going for with the black tile here?
I don't remember my own vision.
I don't remember what the vision was.
Maintenance repairs, not janitors.
Yeah, okay.
I mean, that makes sense.
Is this dirty?
5, 4, 3, 2, 1.
Alright.
Dang.
I think everything's clean, though.
I think he was able to clean it all up.
Alright, you're ready, Declan, for a great day!
Okay, when do I get to have another mascot?
I wonder, though.
Unlock Resort Loungeers Research.
Uh-oh.
Wait.
Is that under a park?
Resort Loungeer?
Is that how I get to four stars?
Oh, no.
Wait, I messed up.
What?
Oh, no.
I should have done that.
I should have seen.
I should have looked at what my task list was.
Oh no.
No!
We did unlock some more things though, I'm pretty sure.
I can't afford a lot of stuff.
I spent too much money.
Whoa, a high dive!
Oh, sick!
This is so dangerous.
Can you reset?
I don't think so.
Once again.
Okay.
My water park is still thriving.
We'll make the money back easy-peasy.
We will make the money back super fast.
It'll be great.
It's just a matter of The research points.
But maybe we'll get some real smarty pants in here.
You know?
We'll get some super duper smarty pants in here.
If you want you could reload the previous save.
It's okay.
Victor!
Yeah, you're getting back to work.
Alright, let's open this place.
Uh...
Oh, it says paint guests.
Can I literally, like, paint the guests?
Alright, where's the guests, Braylon?
I painted one.
I painted two.
That hurts.
They hate it.
Hey, what the hell?
Get out of here!
You didn't pay?
Wait, they go inside anyway.
Oh wait, they have wristbands.
What are you, like a subscriber or something?
I have to paint the guests.
Okay, now I have to get back to Clara Loft.
Declan, we're counting on you today.
Awesome, water!
Yay!
Oh, everybody's...
Fun surprise splash!
You love it, you love it, you love it!
You love it, you love it.
Caden!
Red face equals didn't pay.
Oh, okay.
How are they just walking in then?
Wait, you?
Oh, I think I got him.
I caught a vandal!
Yes.
Get out of here, Eli.
You.
I caught a cheater!
can eat her.
Yeah, Harmony.
Yeah, with your fat ass.
Get out of here.
Yeah, I'm shaming you.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, and I'm gonna tase you too.
Yeah.
That could have killed her.
I will die of starvation if I don't get the money.
Can't anybody in for free.
I'm gonna go I'm gonna- Oh, they can buy tickets here!
I just assumed everybody was...
Not paying!
Hey!
Oops!
Oh, they paid $2 to sit on my bench.
Good job, good job.
Surprise splash!
Any smarty pants?
Any smart people around here?
Oh, that's not what I meant to do.
Oops, my bad.
Hopefully I didn't have to pay for that.
Excuse me.
Oh, yeah.
Get on in here.
When I hand out the flyers, it really feels like that, uh...
That, what's it called, GIM?
Retro Rewind.
Come on.
So boring.
Yeah, that's what I called your mom last night.
Buddy?
Hit me.
Yeah.
Oh,
okay, awesome.
How's my...
Get out of here.
Oh, snacks.
Yes, waited too long for hot dog.
I'm sorry.
No, you were smarty pants.
No smarty pants.
No Smarty Pants, you gotta give me the research, please!
No, I need it, I need it!
Hold on.
Love that splash!
Oh yeah, five dollars for jumping in.
Love it, loved it.
Shoot.
Yes, a senior!
For four hours.
Slide past none.
Eh.
Six hours, you're not a senior.
Don't lie to me, Benjamin Button over here.
Molly, senior slide pass, four hours.
Deliver burns, sells the pools, Sasuga racketeering.
Yeah, let's go get some granola.
Yep, thank you.
Goodbye.
Huh, can you imagine seeing somebody, like, running their
park like this?
Like, jumping over hills and...
Like just running like an absolute maniac across the way.
Just trying to do everything.
Death.
I kill you.
Yeah, stay down.
Tasing gas, yeah.
Literally never letting them be happy.
Shoveing my broom in their face.
Yeah, Claire.
Yeah, you deserve it.
Come here.
Where'd she go?
Did she actually leave?
Not on my watch.
Miss Minnie Mouse over here.
You need to stay down.
We have to show, we have to like show that they're, you
know, that vandals and cheaters will be punished.
Not trash in my...
Cool!
At least there's no poopy.
Except you.
Oh, oh, you got it.
Yeah, that's right.
Yeah.
No space.
Oh, here we go.
We'll just hold on to the trash bag.
Oh, wow!
Have 1,000 visitors use your slides!
Cool.
Did you see that?
new research point yippee Molly Molly Molly Molly
wait did you get it did you get it?
There we go Stinko Victor may move and Victor deserves a
little bit of a break you know actually where is that guy
I saw another stink oh no it's a trash can Which is worse, I
wonder.
Vandalism or loitering?
Everybody deserves to be exploded.
Criminal scum, be explode.
That's how I believe in my philosophy.
Criminal, oh.
Yes, yes, yes.
We can add mustard.
I hope you don't mind weak old.
We cold hot dogs.
How would they tell?
How would they know?
Just like burn on.
Exactly, exactly.
You know exactly.
Where's my staff?
Hot dog.
Add mustard.
Of course.
There you go.
There's like 7-Eleven hot dogs.
In point.
Secret combo.
Oh, wait.
What do you mean?
It's...
Lemonade sand does not need to be restocked.
I want lemonade.
Wait.
Oh, he's doing it.
That was weird.
It said it needed to be restocked, but it didn't at all.
Wait, what's dirty?
Is this dirty?
Oh, yeah, it's pretty dirty, actually.
Maybe that's what they meant.
Yeah, funny glitch.
Funny glitch.
Oh, research point.
Yes.
Don't even happen to you, buddy.
Dang.
Actually, I got...
I was making curry last night.
And my...
Oh, my stupid head was holding the potato peeler.
Like, my thumb was pressed upon the...
the like blade of it all and so i have like this big old big
old cut on my um
on my um my thumbnail
did the kitchen survive bear i barely survived i barely
survived i mean i'm already dead But the kitchen is a
dangerous place for a ghost, I think.
Add both.
Alright, Roshel.
Connor!
I love when they moonwalk.
Someone's peeing in the pool!
Wait, who?
Where?
Oh.
Is it you?
Who's peeing in the pool?
How do I kill you?
Wait.
Hey.
We all make mistakes like that sometimes I didn't even think
about it until afterwards and I didn't even notice and then
I was like wait a second my finger I was like why is my
finger hurt?
Hello lemonade at ice
Oh hi Victor don't look at this I didn't mean it
Drowning in his own peace He deserves it.
Oh, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice.
Oh, I need more Smarty Pants.
Decoration needs improvement.
We have 59.
Oh.
59 people upset about it.
Some attractions were dirty.
Some attractions aren't in great condition.
I got bullied.
Oopsie.
Oh, I love chucking full trash bags across the park.
Oh, hello?
We're closed?
Sure?
I want lemonade?
Mm-hmm.
Thanks.
Sure thing.
We have four.
So we'll need, what was it again?
The park?
Training?
Oh yes, because we gotta get to the resort lounger.
So let's do this.
Snacks now reach guests before they get grumpy.
Hammer upgrade level 2!
Wait, that's pretty nice.
Alright.
Always two minutes before closing the banning stuff, right?
Ah.
It ain't easy running a park like this.
Alright.
I think we're good to sleep.
We'll just do everything in the morning.
This is where I get paid to be bullied by Minto.
I can bully.
you for free the bullies are free the bullies are free all
right we're gonna just repair everything we'll let we'll let
Victor do all the cleaning how
could I both how would how do you want a bully um hey smelly
oh you smell so bad and And it makes me sick.
Oh.
We'll
have a bad throw.
If you were trash.
It would be really stinky as bad.
And you would also...
Oh my god!
This poor chair has been in such disrepair.
I didn't even notice it there.
Retro Rewind mentioned.
Thanks for reminding me I got some new titles to add to the
mod.
Ideas come from chat, so let me know if you got one.
My iBoo's.
Oh, thank you!
Well, of course, go back to Retro Rewind.
Eventually, just kind of whenever I feel like playing it.
This one I went to because of the update.
Oopsie.
I think I repaired everything.
I wish I would show me, you know.
Oh, these also need to be repaired.
Good to know.
Bully me like one of your French girls.
Whoa!
Cute accent.
Authentic phantom accent.
Let's...
Oh, Clover Cove!
Wait, double rectangle.
Wow!
Now this one I think this is deserving of a high level.
jump right like this oh yeah all right and also we want some
more decorations we are being told that our decorations are
not enough of what is this kind of fountain I don't quite
understand creates a relaxing atmosphere with flowing water
what the heck is this oh this is another fountain we'll put
some more treason how
much money I have a flower bed oh I don't know wait this is
a good this is good here here okay all right let's go build
it all
because we also need more fountains for our quest so this
would be the fifth one out of ten yeah nice all right fill
her up baby dive right into the umbrella no yes just don't
be stupid none of my patrons are dumb how dare you imply
that how dare all right watch this
I think I should put in maybe some more loungers over here
though oops if I have the cash to do so utility yeah yeah
we'll put in some restrooms a rainfall shower wow
position snap yeah we're gonna position snap is now we'll
put in some loungers yeah yeah like oh am i out of cash i
think so that's all right um oh oh good i do have money for
a trash can Okay, cool.
Okay, um, maybe if we unlock the popcorn stand.
And then I can, uh, add it over here or something.
Wait, what is with the spam today?
What's going on?
More capacity is going up.
Oh, cool.
I didn't even notice.
More money, more money.
Yeah, weird spam today.
Weird spam today.
If I miss any, you know, you can always be like, spam, weird
spam person.
Alright.
I think we're good.
I have $16 to my name.
Whoa!
Dance accord, you think it's already about $50?
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
I've just been blocking them.
That's the best thing to do, honestly.
Especially if I accidentally miss it or something, you know?
We have a new pool and new jumping!
Oh yeah!
Victor, did you see that?
Did you see that?
Doesn't care.
Didn't care about anyone.
Gochujang spam?
I missed the...
the free cam, the hot girl cam ones.
And casino ones.
Those are fun.
I miss those spams.
Wait, is he going to our new pool?
Oh, I think he is.
I think he is.
Are you going to be the first?
Russell.
Oh, my God.
Russell is bee-lining it.
You got this!
Oh, my God.
Whoa!
I think the pool is a little shallow.
Already?
Talia, how do you come to a water park?
How are you so stinky in the morning?
Did you not?
I thought I saw more stinky.
It was my imagination.
Another stinko!
Why are we so stinky in the morning?
Is Russell okay?
Don't worry about it.
Come on, come on!
Uh-oh.
Get in there.
I'm going to push you in and you're going to have to pay to
use it.
Oh, Russell.
Of course.
Add both.
Of course my king.
It's their morning shower.
Disgusting.
We have an evil person.
I'm sorry to everybody.
Wait, who was it?
I'm sorry to everybody in the pool.
Oops.
I think I got the wrong one.
Oh, shoot.
Hide the evidence.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Wait, who was the evil one?
Who was the evil?
The evildoer.
There's our evil doer.
Welcome to what?
Get the med kit.
You're right.
We can save you.
You're fine.
They got up like nothing happened.
Right back to...
Right back to it.
Welcome to Kmart.
Oh, like the...
Oh.
No, no, no, watch out!
Watch out!
The place across the street.
We got a new research point.
Let's go.
Oh, somebody's waiting on a hot dog.
And somebody's drowning.
Add both.
I'm just...
I just...
I don't want to, like, upset you, but you're the reason this
person is not getting help.
Wait.
Oh, my God.
This is the lady we saved earlier.
Nice.
Hot dog over life.
Like, life is over for you.
There's more graffiti.
Lawyer up?
Who are you to tell me to lawyer up, huh?
Oh, watch out, watch out.
Hot dog is life.
Hot dog, everybody.
Hot dog.
Hot dog, hot dog.
Evil.
Yeah, that's right.
I catch you before you even do the act.
I see the evil.
Oh no, waited too long for a ticket.
Uh-oh, wait, wait.
Senior pass.
Six hours, slide pass.
Koa.
Senior, four hours, slide pass.
Yes, yes.
Brailin, you need to tell me when you're gonna stand on the
couch.
Thank you for the hot dog, Takizu.
You didn't tell me when you're doing that.
Anybody waiting on a dog?
Oh, yes.
We do, we do, we do.
And a research point, thank you.
What do you want?
Colton, add ketchup.
Ooh, that was close.
They almost ran out of time.
Where's our customers?
What a kid.
His shoe is off the couch.
Braylon, you're being a little like...
No one likes a quirky guy like this.
okay i don't need you to be i don't pay you to be lull so
random i need you to do your job okay braille
i ken has paycheck he says eight hours holy cow carmen you
you're awesome no hot dog no life new season coming soon
Oh, Braylon's back.
Yummy, yum, yum, yum.
Are people still not enjoying the decorations, you think?
I think I still need to do better.
They dropped their science.
Going hard.
Stinky trash.
Thank you trash.
9 out of 10.
Watch this.
10 out of 10.
Watch out, Molly.
8 out of 10.
How?
How even...
Nice.
10 out of 10!
Thank you so much for the 50!
Thank you so much!
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Another 50.
Thank you so much.
Is this water...
Wait, are you a pe...
Oh, that's a poop!
I have to grab it with my bare hands.
I'm so sorry, everybody.
Don't look.
It's just a prop.
Carmen, you're my best customer.
I can't throw it at you.
Oh, no, don't be sick.
Connor, don't do it.
Wait, did you trip over that or?
Everybody stop stepping on the...
Oops.
Wait, what did I just do?
Dang it.
Yeah.
Oh, uh-oh.
Mallory is drowning.
Gosh, dang it, Mallory.
I can't go two seconds without you.
More throw up.
Who's getting sick at the water park?
You know what?
Oh, it's probably like a norovirus or something.
Uh-oh.
No, I keep my pools clean?
Except when stinky people like Pahlia come in.
Oh my gosh.
That's a corny thank you for another 50 gifts.
Holy!
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
Uh-oh.
We got a drowner.
Skylar, I got you!
Hey.
The lettuce.
No, no, no.
We don't serve lettuce here.
Only a hot dog.
Whoop, there's another- oh.
Someone really is like- is dumping in all of my- all of my
pools at the moment.
I think I have a literal vandal.
Did you just throw up?
No.
I think I have an actual vandal on the loose.
Someone's peeing in the pool!
Oh!
We were so close.
Wait, who's peeing?
You!
Wait, was it actually you?
No, it's you!
Yara!
Yara, come here.
Where are you?
Wait, where'd she go?
We lost her?
Thank you!
Thank you so much for the hug, I survived the gifting!
Thank you so much!
Welcome to Kmart.
The lettuce parasite strikes.
Everything is really pooed up right now.
Oh, hold on.
Yes.
Lemonade out of ice.
There you go, Dozo.
So sorry, I had to see that, Carmen.
My smelly.
Oh, there's a poop in here, too?
Ew.
Oh.
Victor, where were you?
Victor, we needed you.
someone's waiting for oh oh my god i went to go get more
stuff for the lemonade stand i was wondering where he went
regina wants lemonade add lemon oh
did that glenn you good so far everybody is happy poop
pirate i don't know we got a drowner i don't know why we
have so many people pooping in my pools today the lettuce
virus is It's been two weeks.
The incubation period really took off for everybody.
I love Declan.
He is doing his best.
I didn't know that he would go get me more.
Oh, they like the decorations.
They like the decorations.
I didn't know he would get me more, more lemonade stuff.
That's so awesome of him.
He's going above and beyond.
He's my greatest employee.
Oh, maybe I do need more toilets.
I think I can get more.
Because...
Wait, it's a utility, right?
Yeah, we can get more.
We'll just, uh...
How do I rotate it again?
Rotate?
There we go.
Alright.
Nobody likes to show off, Declan.
Don't be mean to Declan.
Don't be mean to him.
Raylan is too tired.
Uh-oh.
Wait, we gotta...
We gotta push her.
Oh.
Hold on.
Addison?
There we go.
I pushed you in.
And you pay me.
Win-win.
Alright, we've got five research points.
Five research points.
Great job today.
Why does Victor...
I don't know why.
He decides that he will finish his shift in the trash can.
He says, please, boss, I am but I'm here.
I could not do my job today.
I am nothing but...
I do... I'm nothing but trash.
I belong here.
Nice.
10 out of 10 throw.
Let's go.
I am but I'm here.
Weasel.
I'm looking for science.
But I do not see any, unfortunately.
We did get to six research points, though.
Let's see how much our next thing was.
Six points!
And then we can get the resort loungers!
Yeah!
Nice, nice, nice.
Oh, perfect.
I want the baseball bat.
I'm hearing this stream at work.
I feel very motivated.
Supervisor Mint keeps them in line if you don't if you are
not willing to listen you're just gonna have to listen with
force that's what I always say we could do e-tickets my
little e-ticket okay let's go to sleep our hammer is gonna
be super awesome tomorrow good morning world and especially
zanzibar land everybody ready for a for an excellent day of
money money money money yes boss i can't wait to be paid oh
watch this
And this, this is a training for...
The guy I pay to clean up it, clean it up.
Oh my gosh, Victor, who would, who would throw their...
Their trash over the...
Over the... Oh, who would do that?
Over the fence?
My gosh!
No respect these days, huh?
Stinky ghosts?
We have none of those here.
Only minty fresh ghosts.
Azanzabar land.
You can count on minty fresh time.
Oh, my taser.
Get these.
Wow, already.
And such a disrepair after one day.
Wow, even this, wow.
I guess I really did need more showers, huh?
Shocker.
Erian for a shocking time at Zanzibar Land.
Criminal scum.
Get shocked.
Even the criminals are shocked by these deals.
And these super fun times.
times.
Here, I'll help you out, Victor.
This one's really dirty.
This one's dirty, dirty.
Nice.
I'm watching it.
I'm watching it get clean.
Nice.
Great job, buddy.
What about this one?
All right, whatever.
Because you don't pay me to get every shower.
You don't even pay me to shower.
Oh, here.
You're so right.
I don't pay you to shower.
showers.
Nice.
Shocked by the value.
And the manager's taser.
Let's see.
Maybe we can do some more.
Oh, wait.
The popcorn stand.
I can't afford it.
We are kind of saving up for like the resort loungers, but I
think it would be fun to have a popcorn stand as well.
Right?
We'll just kind of decorate this area over here a little
bit.
We'll make the money back, because I have to make the money
back anyway for like you know oh wait uh wait can i hire
more people no
rename park no visitor's thoughts yet oh i can get a loan
whoa
build okay hmm utility popcorn stand we'll do it like right
here Right here.
Do some trash can.
And some decoration.
Wait, what's this one?
Oh, hot dog, hot dog.
Look at that.
Is that not, is that not just so aesthetically pleasing to
the eyes?
I want to know what kind of fountain this is.
I'll put it in.
and then everything has like a fountain and stuff or like a
diving board or something crazy so um we'll do some shaders
some some of these here wait okay oh this is a fancy kind of
umbrella Ooh, la-la.
Hmm.
I'm not quite sure what I want to do yet.
We'll do this funky totem pole.
I don't know what the theming of our park is at all.
The theme is pool.
Minto!
Hope the doll of you didn't scare you.
Waterpark is looking so aesthetically pleasing.
Thank you!
Wow!
Oh, I forgot one.
That's okay though.
Oh yeah.
Wait, do I need to go buy popcorn now?
We'll go do that, then open this door.
Wait.
How much more lemon in do I mean?
And the dog.
We can get a box of dog, a box of lemon in.
And popcorn.
Yeah.
Lemonade?
Dog?
Popcorn.
I want this royal hammer.
We'll have to really save up for it, though.
Is the dog stand facing back?
It's facing this way.
So you kind of like look at the...
You see?
Alright.
Hey, hey, hey, hey.
I...
Oh, actually that worked perfectly.
I probably should get another one of these as well.
The life rings over over here.
So we're gonna do this as well.
I put it right smack dab right there.
Alright, alright.
Are you guys ready for a great day?
Yeah, Berlin!
Get soaked!
Get soaked your morning soaking-ing!
Alright, open park.
Daklin, your morning soaking!
Where are you, Victor?
Victor, you need to get soaked.
Surprise, splash.
Oh, yeah.
Look, he's advertising how wet you get here.
Isn't that crazy?
Regina, oh, you did want to come here.
Oh, sorry.
Everybody here is so fragile.
Ah!
Is that Keso?
No, no, no, Mario.
It's me!
The benefit
of the job?
Free morning shower?
Exactly, exactly.
Ooh, wouldn't want that.
Welcome.
Okay.
Build a fountain.
Is that what I have to do?
Anybody want popcorn?
Nobody?
Stinko alert.
Almost Ezekied.
There's like a game I saw that's out.
That's like, I got Ezekied, and now I'm asking the truck to
help me succeed in the new world or something.
I thought it looked pretty cute.
I wasn't planning on streaming yet, but I saw it was out.
I was like, oh, wow.
Truckkun, yeah, yeah.
I was like, truckkun.
Get splashed.
So refreshed.
What are you doing?
You caught a pervert.
You pervert Yara.
Yara, you're so disgusting.
Disgusting, nasty.
Taking pictures of who?
Who are you taking a picture of?
Haven?
Oh yeah, oh yeah.
Lookit, we got lines.
Everybody is wanting to come in.
I can hand out these last two at least.
Journey, you've been here before.
Yeah, having a blast.
Oh, oh, oh.
My bad.
What about you?
Colton bringing a camera to water park is crazy look I don't
want to say we attract the freaks but oh hello I want
popcorn add butter theater butter okay oh I did too no one
saw that right what did you do a cheater oh at least he paid
for the I guess?
Raylan is too tired.
Oops, my bed.
Oh, he's Victor's cleaning up.
Alright, we're gonna have to let people in.
Wow.
Victor is tired too!
Oh, no, no!
Wait, I was gonna do something.
I can't remember what.
Oh.
Oh, okay.
It's Victor's today to be a little quirky.
There's somebody over there.
Six hours.
Adult.
Slide pass.
Hello, Maggie.
Eight hours.
Teen.
Slide pass.
Oh, geez.
Build a fountain.
No.
Teen.
Slide pass.
I gotta go.
Oh my gosh.
Why did you go up there if you were gonna be such a baby
about it?
Someone's peeing in the pool!
Sorry.
Sorry, Levi.
Don't mind me.
Is it you?
Oh.
We have some...
casualties?
We have some, uh...
Additional casualties!
There you go.
Hello, Connor.
Senior.
Six hours.
Slide pass.
There, uh, dojo.
Collateral damage.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Senior slide pass.
It's another peer.
Another peer.
Who is it?
Is it you?
I got caught a soda drunk.
What the heck does that mean?
Does that mean they pee in pools?
I'm drunk on soda?
It's a really hazy day today, isn't it?
golly watch out everybody anybody waiting on no no popcorn
waiters okay so vending machine is a very stocked all right
oh I'm running a business I'm running a business someone's
peeing again what's with the peers today we got peers all
Was it you?
Yeah, seriously?
You're disgusting.
And I want you out of my park.
In fact, I'm gonna tase you too.
Oh.
I'm so sorry, sir.
You didn't see that.
I'm picking up my science.
Oh my gosh, there's so much trash everywhere.
Everywhere needs to be.
Do you think they're gonna complain about getting bullied?
Oh, sorry.
Excuse me.
Victors.
Oh, lemonade's in.
Is it where we're stocked?
That's okay.
We got this.
It's right here.
No, it doesn't.
He got it, actually.
He's a great worker.
Just finished a 14-hour shift today.
Have some of my overtime pay, boss.
As you know!
What the heck?
That is your overtime!
Don't give it that me.
I don't give it that much.
Welcome to Kmart.
So much pee.
Yes, waited too long for popcorn.
Yay, mint.
Yay, Danny!
Is the bullying a complaint or a perk?
I guess it really depends on the person, huh?
Unfortunately, I fear that our park may have...
Oh!
What are you?
Yeah.
Our park may have people that would not appreciate the
intricacies and...
Wait, who's peeing?
Oh, no.
You?
Wait, who's peeing?
Isn't someone peeing?
It looks yellow.
Maybe the water's dirty.
Everybody, too much peeing.
Too much pee, sorry.
Someone... Oh my god, more pee in!
the pool is it you yeah caught a peeing visitor being
bullied is a is an art that only those with open minds and
hearts can appreciate you know what I mean stinko stinko
alert it's like it's like a dog you got to get them right as
they do with that guilty look on their face they're just
looking at you like
sorry i'm peeing sorry i'm peeing sorry i'm peeing i'm
peeing and pooping right where i eat oh no somebody waited
too long for a hot dog no no prince please be happy yeah
yeah he's happy My prince!
Okay, Braylon, you're doing a good job.
Wait, what did you want?
Oh, there's garbage.
Oh, no.
Even though I have trash cans everywhere.
Oh, oops.
I'll kill the litterers.
Yes.
Build a fountain.
I will, but I have no place to put them.
Okay.
Honestly, I'm not... Actually, we'll talk to Laura so we can
get the next...
I mean, Clara, what's her name?
Clara.
So we can get the next thing, yeah.
Ancient civilizations left messages for future generations.
Perhaps it's time we shared a few expedition notes.
Give flyers to pedestrians.
Okay, easy.
Brela, no!
Frederick, I'm trying to do a quest right now.
Is your life so important?
Does someone...
Anyone?
waiting on why do i need to build a fountain anyway i guess
we'll just do it huh everything's asking me is it under
decoration yeah these ones are cool people tend to like
these ones so we'll just put another one right there let's
go build it all right uh i built the fountain oh someone's
waiting for a hot tub but it still says build fountain i'm
not sure why mustard and we got a popcorn person excuse me
i want popcorn add chili lime oh no
i think that means you already placed one down and didn't
build oh this one you're right i completely forgot that i
didn't build this one oh oh wow cool oh you're right oh mate
the one that got away in another life you want chili lime i
give it to you and then you walk to the end of the line in
another life popcorn in your hands i'm
gonna take your money again and that's why the game was
bugging to build a fountain yeah I thought it was like some
weird what's the word something for okay tomorrow we'll
definitely be able to build a resort loungers I'd say yeah I
thought it was like a like a something for a quest but
clearly not tomorrow
morning we'll give the flyers out and we can build three
more mafia running a place like this ain't cheap huh repair
staff angry customers if you need money I have plenty of it
take these 2,000 no contracts no paperwork just trust
between businessmen what's the boss doing here I don't think
I need mine either okay Excellent.
I always appreciate loyal business partners.
Just don't forget who helped you out.
Oh, wait.
It backfired?
I caught a mafia.
Friendly fire.
Oh, I got a new research point somehow.
get the loungers that would be huge i folded under the
pressure guys i couldn't handle it i couldn't handle the
pressure did i actually give money though oh yeah he did he
gave me 2 000 bucks for free the loans are free this is what
you guys meant by free super Wow!
The loans are free!
You guys should have said so!
Yeah, it's free, it's free!
I get it now, I get it now.
Yeah, good job.
Free loans with zero consequences ever!
Ever, ever, ever.
Sick.
Just like the people at my park.
I keep throwing up and pooping in my pools.
We'll help out Victor quite a bit, because there's a lot in
this park now.
I can run around fast, but my boy's a little slow.
I like how I have this bench here.
Right there.
Excellent placement.
Watashi.
Sike!
AHHHHH!
Miki, Miki, Miki, Miki, Miki, Miki, Miki.
Miki, Miki, Miki, Miki, Miki.
Oh, that's your second Nakatono!
No!
Okay, sir, I have to thank you.
Okay.
This is fine.
We just gotta clean up.
Fix up.
Alright, I think we're good to...
Oh, wait, look.
We already have four research points.
How much was it again?
Five.
Oh, we are so in, baby.
We are so in.
All right.
Raylan, you ready?
Did you want one?
What the?
I think somebody died.
Yara, Yara, you have to...
Oh, Yara, you're a freakazoid.
I don't want you at my...
Oh my gosh, everybody's dying.
Don't yawn at my efforts, please.
It's rude.
You want one?
Just don't forget, we helped you out.
Mallory.
Yeah.
You want a ticket.
I know you do.
Mario.
average day in New York City hit me I dare you we had the
sick slow-mo did everyone see that oof ouch my bones I'll
never be able to pay for my surgery unless you come to me my
water park oh I'll never oh oh don't you feel bad for me oh
my bones hurt oh my every bone hurts I'll never We'll never
live unless you come to my water park.
All right, how are we doing here?
Let's go back to Clara Loft.
Who lives in this museum.
Uh-huh.
All right, yes.
I've encountered some unusual scents during my expeditions.
A few guests are adding new entries to the list.
I'd rather not document them all.
Care to help me avoid the paperwork?
Oh, we gotta clean up smelly people.
I wonder what we get once we like finish this, like these
quests.
I guess we unlock the Aztec stuff maybe?
Yes, it's very clean.
Yes, I take care of my park.
Nobody's swimming.
The smell, the smell.
The loungers.
Wait, I think we can do it now.
Advanced marketing!
Flyers, we're fine in the early days, but it's time to go
bigger.
Unlock poster marketing in the research tree.
Buy posters in the store and hang them around town.
Where do I do that?
Where is that?
Not maintenance, surely.
An attraction?
Suspiciously cute automobile misfortune Marketing tree?
Wait, where?
Where do you see it?
Unlock poster marketing research.
Am I crazy?
Oh,
we can do the park size.
Let's do that.
Buy a zipline tower.
expand park three times normal or hard difficulty let's oh
here okay so we gotta get the zip line and then we'll get
the poster marketing okay got it what a funky tree
whoa wow whoa free cars well this one this one looks like
it's in decent shape this one's missing some tires no it's
not wait they're both in decent shape Free car!
Free car!
Wait.
Is this okay?
Braila, no.
Stinko alert.
The stinkos are on the prowl.
Oh.
Don't look at me.
He like was looking at me.
Before I got him.
Okay.
Sell, sell, sell.
For real, though.
Why aren't we selling this?
Oh, oh, I didn't hear.
Oh, my gosh.
I thought adult.
Okay.
I thought it would be like, Ding, ding.
Someone's waiting for a ticket.
Four hours, teen.
Are you sure you don't?
We gotta upsell the slide pass.
We need you to want the slide pass.
Maybe we'll get rid of all other attractions except the
slides, you know?
I mean yeah slide pass imagine being I don't know I've been
it has been a long time since I've been to a water park but
being there for eight hours sounds insanity that's a grown
woman I gave them the wrong ticket wait what did I give them
the wrong ticket wait what was it oh do they oh I thought
the slide pass was checked oh no get your money's worth
right I guess so senior I thought it was checked yeah you
can be a prune for real I guess if you like gall and you
kind of like you lie oh my staffers five feet apart because
they're not get you sitting in the break room five feet
apart waited too long for a hot dog well sorry I was
handling what's going on here why do you have trash floating
around you what the hell we have a magician
a wizard actually we have a wizard
Maverick would like eight hours.
Oh, you can handle this, Braylon.
Thank you very much.
The Trashmaster.
Is he still around?
Oh, Maggie.
I'm so sorry.
Oof.
Not again.
Eight hours at big water park is fun.
The sunburn afterwards is significantly less so.
Yeah, like I feel...
I feel like maybe if you...
like go but then you're also kind of you know um you sit
around you uh maybe like go under the towel not the towel
the the umbrellas for a bit you gotta eat you know yeah
there's food and stuff to do yeah can't be totally
completely wait what's uh Vending machine is restarted.
Oh, hello.
Lemonade.
Oh, no.
Uh-oh.
Oh, someone else is drowning.
Declan is getting the stuff.
Someone's panicking.
Oops, I'm so sorry.
Lemonade, add ice.
I got you, I got you.
Just be a little more patient, a little more patient.
Why is everybody drowning today?
What's happening?
What's going on?
Did we all go to the water park?
Just not knowing how to swim?
Colton is injured.
Who?
Who's injured?
Oh, there was another drowner.
All right, buddy.
Come on.
Oh, this disgusting pool.
Oh, yikes.
All right, hold on.
Come here, man.
Oh.
There you go.
Everybody out of...
Someone else is drowning.
Why is everybody drowning today?
They're faking it for attention.
That's why I, like, throw the thing at them.
I don't even give them a second glance.
Popcorn add butter.
Alright, there you go.
You're welcome.
Oh.
Watch your step.
I don't even know how she did that.
Oh.
Oh, just Just thought you needed a little Oh, don't worry
about it
Everybody here is made of paper for real though Oh, someone
ran out Uh-oh, I got a vandal, I think Alright, get out of
this pool, it's disgusting Mallory Mallory, you can do this
There you go Alright
Glass bones and paper skin.
More drowning!
Can't thank you enough.
Yeah, you honestly should.
How do I...
How do I add more...
How do I put these back on?
It's so frustrating.
I think someone's waiting for popcorn.
Just kidding, I'm a liar.
This is awesome!
Drowns.
The currents must be in full force today.
Oh, we only have two.
What were we trying?
Okay, it was under attraction, the zipline tower.
Connect distant locations with speedy aerial routes.
This is gonna be huge.
you guys know that like that audio sound like the the tick
tock audio that's just like i don't know what it's from i
think it's from one of those like um one of those like tv
reality show things like a like tlc or something but it's
just this girl being like i feel like you're here just for
the zip line and then the guy is just like huh i feel like
that will be everybody coming into my park panicking on the
diving board oh no they waited too long for popcorn why
didn't you say something i
think you should leave victor oh cool water is dirty someone
took unwanted photos of me I saw something disgusting.
Attractions were dirty.
Oh, wait, wait, but we had 227 say.
I feel fun.
The decoration is acceptable.
I had a good rest.
I used clean attraction.
I think that's a win.
Oh, oopsie.
That went somewhere.
I think we had an absolute win of a day.
Goodbye, everybody.
Goodbye.
I got you, Mario.
Oh, I got you.
I'll take you to safety.
I wonder how many people die in front of my house.
By house, I mean tent.
All right, team.
Let's get repairing and stuff.
Mama Mia.
Here I go again.
My, my.
How can I resist you?
Mama Mia Meow Meow Meow Meow Meow Meow Meow Meow Meow Meow
Meow Meow
Meow Meow Meow Meow Meow Meow Meow New research boy Yippee
Oh this one's disgusting too
All right all right oh All right all right clean nice and
clean nice and clean some of these don't ever need to be
clean dollars you think she wouldn't sleep in a tent anymore
all my money goes back to my part what can i say i i'm
married to the job i'm married to the job all right watch
this
i the game only gave me an eight out of ten out of that one
that's insane that was a hundred out of ten if i've ever
seen one before a million out of ten sick throwing people
be using the diving board Wow very good very good Victor
you're cleaning and I'm repairing we're we're doing it we're
dueling it we give you a hundred out of ten thank you yeah
they don't appreciate my craft my skills I'm wasted here I'm
wasted here
Call me a Lady Laker.
Maybe we should take care of some of these things at the
back.
They ask how you are and you just have to say you're fine
when you're really not fine.
But you just can't get into it because they will never
understand.
Yeah, sad song.
No, well, you know what one of my favorite things is,
though, that, like, that girl.
I've mentioned it before.
But the girl that's like, the world is on fire.
Everybody hates each other.
The animals are dying.
The aliens are not contacting us.
But do you really need anything else?
Get...
Yeah,
the trick-shodding montage.
I watch every single one of them.
They get me every time.
I'm like, yeah!
Wait, it's under attractions, that's right.
It's really tempting to get the inflatable vending machine,
I'm holding it.
Wait, I think we should get a small water blob.
No, I'm just one point away from the zipline tower and then
we need six more points for the poster marketing.
What's my park at?
Three.
Can I clean this up a little?
Yeah.
Let's get my sledgehammer.
Oh, can't carry one.
What is this?
Oh, can only carry one, that's what I meant.
She said the animals are leaving, but where are they going?
I mean, cows are being abducted by aliens, like every day,
you know?
Like all the time.
Shit.
They're going to Animal Planet.
Oh.
This doesn't look bad.
Wait, am I really just destroying these cars?
Okay.
That's why beef is so expensive.
Mmm, beef.
I think I want tacos for dinner tonight.
One thing I wanted to get when I was in LA was some good
street tacos.
I forgot.
Is that Victor?
What are you doing, buddy?
I
mean, taco sounds pretty tasty.
Is it taco Saturday evening?
They're so good, I know!
Texas has some great tacos, I bet, I bet.
I love me a good taco, baby.
Jimmy Chang!
Just ordered pizza.
Pizza on a Saturday.
They say it's almost as good as pizza on a Friday.
Everybody be saying it.
all right let's grab some more snacks
excuse me I wish I could get a loan for $100,000
okay that one's full oh screw it we'll just open it we'll
just yeah all right we got a box of hot dogs let's go get
box of lemonades and box of popcorns Surprise!
Welcome to membership!
Everybody say welcome!
Mooy mooy boo!
Welcome home!
Everybody say it right now.
I hope you enjoy the attention!
Are we supposed to say all of that?
Pick your favorite, pick your favorite, pick what speaks to
you the most.
I feel I feel like I should not be oh oh that's why I
thought look you can see sorry Declan he just rag dolled
over there oh he's a magician how did he do that your
talents are wasted here your talents are wasted here but you
can see with the car that's why I thought it had no tires
but when you get close it has tires I think what I'm gonna
do is build a cool little pool here yeah we'll build
something like this yeah yeah yeah awesome awesome I
like how we have just a million like different types of cool
cool we should get this area someday we have a million
different like tiny pools nothing nothing substantial all
right that should be good let the car swim too right that
cost me a lot of money I just noticed grand shell pool
seashell reef board when do I get this research ocean diving
platform okay okay
the people want more pools the people want more pools people
want our pools people
want our
Here, since we did this pool, I'll even get some more
decorations.
I don't even know what the heck these gift boxes are for.
But they're kind of fun.
And balloons.
For no reason.
Just because?
This looks like a you who, like a like a Sims, they're gonna
woohoo in the pool kind of situation.
I'm a little nervous about it.
Swapping the question.
With what money?
With all the money that I have!
I was able to afford it!
You hate her?
You hating on me?
Look, if you think I have no money, if you want a better...
If you want a better...
Experience.
Waterpark.
experience come to my park all right we got to destroy this
thing but this little guy this looks like an alien he stays
the little guy stays wait
why didn't my I guess I guess it was only at 50 huh the
presadoge welcome back thank you the The black eyes are kind
of glorpy, right?
Street Fighter Minto destroying the car.
Yeah, actually.
And that's my car right there, a park.
That's where I park.
Alright, everybody.
Did we need to talk?
No, we did not need to talk to.
Clara Loft.
Look at...
Oh, whoa.
Our park is... Look at this.
This is like...
la la who's gonna be catch me swimming in the heart shaped
pool like am i the only one so disappointed by this by this
park like there's there's like three slides maybe i should
make more slides one two okay maybe we have like four slides
it's just really hard It's just really hard, okay?
I have to... I can't just...
I just... Don't just need the money.
I need the creative insight.
Loungeers, too.
We got loungers.
I'll put another slide...
Once I can afford it.
Colton's waiting for popcorn.
I got you, Colton.
I got you.
I'm running at the speed of light.
What you want on it, buddy?
Add butter.
Great choice.
Okay.
Awesome.
Floor isn't painted and kind of ugly though.
What?
Do you think money grows on trees or something?
Oh.
Not bad.
Sorry, Jackson.
I'll get you up, buddy.
There you go.
This is part of the ride?
Stinko.
Anybody?
Oh, Liam.
Liam, what if we both swam in the heart-shaped pool?
together.
Liam, I'm drowning!
Liam, I'm drowning in the heart-shaped pool!
Liam!
Oh my god!
Only someone so strong could save me.
Do you want popcorn?
No.
Oh.
Prince is waiting for a hot dog.
My prince!
Hello.
What do you want?
Plane.
Okay.
Why is the hot dog $15 but the lemonade is $20?
wasn't there a way to like customize the way you look there
was like a mirror or something that used to be here new
research point the prince brailin served six victor cleaned
eight cleared three trash declin has served one visitor
declin come on buddy we need we need you to we need you to
up come on you need to be screaming from the high heavens
about how great this lemonade is.
Oh!
Death penalty for perverts.
You're a freak, Jennifer!
Chat tosses you a booy.
A booy!
Delaney's having a great time standing there.
She was so excited.
Good job.
Good job, Queen.
Yeah, get them.
Oh, yeah, I got them.
Whoa, Victor, what were you doing in there?
Go full Koharu on the freaks, boss.
I absolutely will.
Hot dogs make people thirsty.
Charging more for lemonade is diabolical, but makes good
business sense.
Wait, really?
Hot dogs, I guess they do kind of make you thirsty huh
excuse me oh i caught a vandal oh my gosh i want popcorn add
chili lime is this is this the same guy that wanted it
yesterday sorry coming through owner of the uh of the
establishment here oh emily wants ketchup and somebody is
drowning
oh come on it's oh my god i'm gonna kill you i'm gonna kill
you myself.
I will kill you myself!
There's an evil.
A foot.
More graffities!
Hot dogs or something.
Oh shoot.
We got people waiting to go in.
Oh my gosh.
Uh, four hours.
Adult.
There are dojo, dojo, dojo, dojo.
Slide pass.
Teen, four hour.
Are you drunk?
I think you're drunk.
Get out of my park.
That was rude.
Okay, what do you want?
Eight hours?
Senior slide pass.
Buddy, you look younger than some of the teenagers coming
in.
Slide pass.
Senior, eight hours.
They're gonna throw a...
Oh, someone's drowning.
Excuse me.
Excuse me!
Lifeguard!
On duty!
It's me!
What did these even do?
We just have chocolates and stuff open on the ground.
Getting wet and soggy.
Isn't that so yummy?
I love the way...
Lemonade Sand Leader.
I love the way when they're on break they just stand there
and don't even face their responsibility.
They're like, I'm on break.
I'm not looking.
is that hot dogs have a carcinogen in them, but the
carcinogen can be nullified with vitamin C, so Minto is
literally selling the relief for the carcinogen at a higher
price.
Wait, seriously?
Wait, what's the...
Wait, what's the carcinogen?
Guess we waited too long for popcorn.
Why did you say something?
Why did you say you were hungry?
Turning my phone off after hours.
Right?
It's quite literally that.
Haven is drowning.
Haven is getting on my last nerves.
Oh my gosh.
Drowning in what?
I can stand in this.
Oh, that's true, Zach.
I mean, though, Zach said that the person that before was
taking pictures of you maybe because you're cute.
My summer outfit!
Maybe.
I'm not the mascot of the water park.
I don't think.
Zipline Tower!
how does it work do I have to build it do I have to build
the zipline utility oh zipline tower no way oh we got bench
oh we got the nice loungers oh how does this work now now I
have to build like a second one right like this
how do I How does it work?
Is it too far?
How does it work?
Wait, how does it work?
You have to build the first one.
So sorry.
Maybe I didn't have enough money for the second one.
We be ziplining?
I think I put this in a terrible spot.
No, I think I'm on.
Alright, here I go.
Adjust ziplining.
Oh
Whoa You
think other people will use it?
That was so fun
Trash Okay, watch this watch this Don't worry about it
How f- oh my gosh, there's so much trash around here.
Oh!
Declan, I'm sorry!
Wait, take trash.
Wait, wait.
Where's all the other trash?
Oh, it's all over here.
Whoops, oops, my bad, my bad.
My bad, my bad.
Victor, where have you been, Victor?
Victor, where have you been?
Victor, it's disgusting here.
Ha ha ha ha!
Victor!
Victor, we need you to...
Someone is peeing in the pool and someone is drowning.
What is our higher priority?
No, not in the love pool.
Okay, they're definitely doing it for attention.
Yay!
Are you wanting someone to perform CPR on you?
Who's peeing?
I'm loving this.
Kenji, you could do anything.
You could have done anything.
Can I take it in reverse?
Whoa!
Oh no, I'm just running.
You can't use it in reverse.
That's not how gravity works, but also, have you seen this
game?
This game is...
Not how gravity works.
Oh, realism in my pool sim.
Someone's peeing in the pool again.
Someone deserves the hammer.
Is it you?
Where are you?
Where'd you go?
Wait, you?
No, not Jalen.
Maybe this one's just gross.
I'm drowning!
I why would you okay you drown and you're going to blame me
I'm sorry but this just seems unfair like you're gonna blame
your inability to swim on my pools make it make sense
just a joke welcome back he signed a waiver at the door yeah
it's a skill issue it's a skill issue Thank you for coming,
Zoraya.
See you again tomorrow.
Just a little love tap.
Alright, let's go to sleep.
We'll grab everything else in the morning.
Yeah, if my pools were better, they wouldn't have drowned.
I know.
It's clearly my fault.
Alright, let's get repair.
in, baby.
I'm cleaning.
Oh, sorry, Victor.
Stolen valor.
Anyway, back to work.
Some drown while others die of thirst.
That's too deep.
I'm gonna move this.
Let's move it like...
Here, maybe.
It's like a little in the way.
but I want to be able to use it easily, you know?
Now we adjust.
Like, what if someone's drowning on the other side?
I gotta be able to get over there pronto.
Or they need...
They need a hot dog.
Hot dog!
Like that, like that, exactly.
Right, that clan?
You could really use that.
Yeah, you can make it faster.
I did, I did.
Super speedy.
Only the best for my loyal customers.
My customers that are so awesome.
They love my park.
They keep coming back even though I tase them.
Even though I shove them.
They actually enjoy it, I think.
Enjoy all the abuse.
Maybe.
That could be them.
They get a kick from it.
They literally go like, woohoo!
Yeah, I bash them with hammers.
And they come back the next day.
They're like, oh man, I got caught.
See you tomorrow.
Okay.
I'm only questioning it a tiny bit.
I think we got everything, actually.
Wait.
Not this guy.
I guess we did.
Oh.
They love it, I swear.
They do!
Why would they be back otherwise?
Okay, I think...
We're pretty close to a...
Our next...
Wait, it was six research points.
So we're pretty close, actually.
Alright, team!
Let's make it a good one!
Good one!
Graylin!
Push that button!
Wait.
$522 overtime payment.
Do I get to play at night?
Going to the pool and Mint beats me up.
Sign me up.
That's what everybody's saying.
Ribble guitarist, thank you so much for 21 months.
Thank you!
Sorry, and I mean to hit my mic with my flash.
Look at this.
Declan, are you ready to have a great day?
You're ready to upsell those lemonades.
Absolutely, he says.
Anything for you, boss?
Had to listen to an instructor explain to a teen they
couldn't spar without physical contact from others getting
sued for drownable water may be possible.
Oh, wait, they couldn't spar without the physical... Wait.
I had no idea that if I went into the water, I might drown.
Where's the waivers?
Where's the signs?
I'm going to eat a little bit of this biscotti biscuit that
I have.
I'm a bit hungry.
And I'm afraid it will get moldy one day.
Hey, Layla.
I don't know where this came from.
I think it was given to me as one of my snacks that I didn't
eat at off-cloth.
Well, I'm getting hungry.
Hungry for dinner.
Did you see the Coyote vs.
Acme trailer?
I never thought I'd be so excited to see a new Roadrunner
cartoon.
We know.
I didn't I didn't honestly I feel like oh my bad I feel like
they've been killing it with some of these like new um like
roadrunner not roadrunner oh we have a we have a bad we have
a bad lady we got a cheater but like some of these new like
cartoon and stuff they've been I've heard good things about
him.
Because John's in on him.
Roadrunner cartoons.
Chili lime.
Thank you for your business.
Stop spraying, man.
Don't come to a water park.
I'm
so glad that we have like super silly
Super silly Games that we can play and quote together They
make me really laugh If anybody hasn't watched my harvester
play through That's where roadrunner cartoons are
it's all thanks to me what do you mean no people are always
suggesting fun games too i always appreciate it brailin okay
okay i got you i got you buddy damn he just left six hours
adult wait but you're you're gonna throw up in my park coro
teen we'll get him we'll get him when he comes in
There we go.
He paid double price.
Slide pass, no.
Oh, someone's drowning.
Do you mind?
Do you mind waiting for a moment?
Thank you.
All right.
Nathaniel, four hours, senior.
Slide pass.
I love it when you play older adventure games.
Me too.
Me too, me too.
Gotta figure out what I play next now.
Six hours, senior, side pairs.
Uh oh, we got a Cinco alert.
We're almost done getting the clean, the, the, the one task.
Who was waiting on a hot dog?
Okay, one second.
You want, add mustard.
Okay.
Dozo!
Sorry, we are out of lemonade right now.
Snatcher!
Nah.
Kamimi is drowning!
No!
She's good.
What do you want?
15, 8 hour pass, slide pass.
Alright.
They're getting closer it almost feels like they're like
they're like what's the word um Blair witching you know or
something Blair witching in the corner together just the
fact that they're oh that they're turned away something
about it is very ominous what a shame roadrunner cartoons we
got two guys He's on break right now.
We got to lock in, guys.
We got to lock in.
Braylon is back to work, baby.
Miriam's waiting on a hot dog.
I've been waiting for Miriam my whole life.
My whole afterlife.
Dozo.
This guy right here.
Come on, Zay.
Oh.
Oh, sorry.
Oh, I thought there was a trash there.
Here, let me help you out.
Ooh!
Look at the batonk-dongs on this lady.
Golly!
Everything good here, Declan?
You're not letting people go hungry, right?
Oh, dang it!
Let me clean this up.
Absolutely bodied.
Someone was peeing?
Oh, in here, in here.
You.
Yeah.
let's go get some more I was really hoping that today we
would be able to get some what's it called some of the like
Aztec stuff but someone's waiting on popcorn I got you wait
I want to get stinky no no no I don't want to slide sorry my
bad sorry new Daniel sorry please get up
I'm on the Claw!
Someone's waiting on popcorn.
What do you want?
Add cinnamon butter.
Okay, I feel like we just barely managed that one.
There's trash in the pool.
Where?
Is it that?
I got it.
Oh, our trash cans are full.
That's why.
Oh my gosh, everything's full.
Victor!
Victor, we need you!
She's so lucky.
Sina butter.
It sounds so good, no?
Ugh.
I guess waited too long for hot dog.
Well, that means they didn't want it enough.
Obviously.
If they wanted it so much, they would have waited forever.
That's my philosophy.
Victor needs help.
I'm the help for Victor.
Uh, who's drowning?
Over there.
Oh.
Charlie, do you need help in the...
No, let me help you out, girlfriend.
It's stuck on our booty.
Just leaves it there.
Tiana wants a hot dog.
It's fine.
Yes?
Add mustard.
Dozo?
I want some sin- I don't know.
Sinabutter sounds really good right now.
I don't know.
Yeah, it's making me think of like a cinnamon- cinnamon roll
or something.
I think I'm just hungry.
I think it's time for me to get dinner soon.
Oh, I'm stuck.
What were we doing?
Oh, Jane's waking up.
I thought.
Oh, I know what I was gonna do.
We were gonna do the research points.
Blaine.
Yo-yo.
Our research points to get the new thing.
Poster marketing, baby!
And someone's peeing in the pool.
Of course they are.
Buy posters in the shop.
Who is peeing?
Now we go talk to Laura Croft.
I mean, Clara Loft.
Clafl- No one's peeing.
The game is a liar.
Do we buy them here?
Oh, sorry, sorry, Braylon.
Do we buy them in here?
Welcome to Kmart.
I guess it's the same ones as before, no?
Oh.
Oh my god, oh my god!
They're on a murderous rampage!
Oh my god!
Can I put them up now?
Braylon, no, I need to do my quest.
Buy posters in the shop.
there we go oh hello four hours senior you don't even have
like that much time at the park left we're closing soon 10
four hours slide pass gotcha the posters are in the market i
looked i must have missed them
eight hours 10 i know somebody's drowning Oh.
Oh, we have the night!
That's right.
Oh my gosh.
It's night time.
Oh, Victor.
Whoa!
The pools light up and everything!
This is crazy.
Mop 1,000 puddles.
That's what I'd be doing with my afterlife.
Can I please get more stuff?
The ruins aren't much fun from the outside the gates.
A few visitors should come take a closer look.
Sell tickets by yourself.
Out of 15.
Okay.
Alright.
Mark it.
Maybe this... Maybe... No?
Do you guys see...
I don't see posters in here.
Buy posters in the shop.
Oh, here!
$500.
Hang the posters around town.
Oh, I need three of them.
I'm trying to get to four stars, baby.
I'm trying to get to four stars.
It's very serious.
Oh, Braylon?
Braylon, are you alive?
Are you taking care of the people?
Oh, he's not.
Oh, my God.
He's on break.
Four hours.
Oh, my gosh.
This is insanity now.
Night shift was a mistake.
Six hours.
Teen.
Slide pass.
Yes, yes.
Take, take, take.
Oh my god.
Oh, thank you, Braylon.
Everybody's waiting too long.
The lemonade needs to be restocked.
The moon is out.
The time, the music is funky.
Everything's funky and crazy in here.
Oh my gosh, the pool.
What was I doing?
Oh yeah.
Unlock basic drink vending machine research.
Um, I'll, let me, how much do we need for that?
Because I remember seeing the drink machine, the vending
machine.
Basic vending machine.
Maybe under park.
Um, here.
Okay.
We just needed three more research points.
Very cool.
Someone's peeing in the pool!
yes seriously i'm very serious okay declin you got this you
got this oh oh oh my gosh just in time baby declin's the man
someone's drowning oh so they are wait they just no wait did
you guys see that that person used the zip line reverse so
it is possible How did they do that?
Wait, how did they do that?
I told you, I told you all, I told you all.
You doubted me, you doubted me.
Someone's peeing, someone's peeing.
I can't tell though, is it you?
That's
me, I slipped on the pee.
Watch out!
Oh, don't walk there!
It's pee!
The purple hair lady?
Did I miss her?
Hold on, I gotta start repairing some of this stuff.
Usually I have time, too, but night shift is scary.
Jane is drowning.
Claire?
Oh.
I think, honestly, doing night shift is not great if you
don't have more workers.
My lesson has been learned.
You don't...
Definitely want to have like a decent amount of people to
take care of the place.
Otherwise, it will go to hell.
Excuse me.
Cool, absolutely full of pigs.
No!
At least it's not full of poop, right?
Oh, Victor's back to work.
Oh, thank goodness.
Victor, we miss you.
Oh!
Okay, yeah!
400 reviews of I Feel Fine!
Let's go!
Someone's panicking on the...
How did that?
How did I get here?
Was it all dream?
Oh my gosh, look at this.
Look at this disgusting.
Oh my gosh, it's so gross.
Night shift moment.
You never know what's gonna happen in the night shift.
We're gonna get crazy research points from this, maybe,
though.
And then we'll be able to, uh...
Hopefully, we'll be able to...
Get it.
How do I look?
P?
How do I pull?
Oh, there it is.
Thank you very much.
Nice.
Oh, some more.
over there too i like that it highlights it oh nice yes yes
the place is so much cooler at night oh it makes me want to
go to like a nighttime nighttime water park i'm sure
someplace must have it where it's like like the you know the
adult swim kids stay out
I'm drowning in the pool.
At night.
Have not heard that referenced in so long.
Oh, here's a puddle.
They do, actually?
Yeah, but, right?
Yeah, they must.
I can imagine it being so popular.
Oh, my God.
Okay, we're almost to five research points.
It might have been five.
Let's double check.
For the basic.
Yes.
Build a drink vending machine.
We have the money to do so.
We 100% do.
Drink vending machine.
We'll do, right?
Oh, angle snap.
There we go.
Rotate?
Or there we go.
I think I only need to build one.
So we'll only build one for right now.
I tried by the zip line, but it was not going through.
It's okay.
Rest... Oh my gosh, everything is a mess right now.
Holy cow.
Everything was falling apart.
Thank God the...
We closed at 11.
Wow.
Everything was actually falling up.
So dirty!
Disgusting!
Let's get this at the moment.
Oh, it was not even, it was at 0% clean.
People were probably growing up.
Um, re- Oh, sell items via your vending machine.
Come on, that sucks.
At least like, Right now, not immediately, you know?
Okay.
Imagine if like wear and tear was this extreme.
Like, you owned a place and every day someone sits on your
bench and it immediately like cracks and crumbles.
I guess if, oh yeah, we gotta restock these guys too.
It does say sell items via your vending machine.
So it doesn't necessarily mean...
Ooh, soda.
It doesn't necessarily mean only my soda one.
It could be any of them.
Inpeccable craftsmanship.
They don't make them like they used to do.
I don't make them like they used to.
I know I could have done all of this stuff in the morning.
But...
I was trying to get as many research points as possible at
the same time.
Does this ever need to get repaired?
Doesn't seem like it.
That's cool.
Wait, what's... what's this?
Oh, I'm just kidding.
The office is a mess!
Ah, nice shift disabled.
Okay, good.
Oh.
Well, well, look who's doing better these days.
I hope you enjoyed the money while it lasted.
Now it's time to settle our arrangement.
You owe me 20,000!
No.
Nobody refuses me twice.
You'll regret this.
20,000!
Whoa, what's going on?
Why is there, like, trash in the air?
What?
What's happening?
Are you a wizard?
Why do we have so many wizards?
He's gonna call us goons.
That's fine.
I have a hammer.
And a taser.
I'll take him out.
Each and every one of them.
I'm not afraid of no goon.
Especially no dragon.
He's summoning something in the air.
Oh, I forgot to clean his.
Hello, Victor.
Top of the morning to you.
He's gonna goon?
Okay, but then I can just call the police on him.
If he's gonna do that in my park.
I'm ready to know baby Doki feels a disturbance in the force
I think I will call it here today though guys I hope you
enjoyed our fun water park antics it seems like they've
added so much more let's wait what was it under B wait wait
wait wait wait wait look at all of these you can get stars I
want the really big ones though hidden ruins platform
research as tech diving platform yeah there's so much more
added so
boom it's crazy i forgot how crazy the game itself is though
might might want to i might want to weigh it a little bit
until when i'm ready
pink it's in to border land review pool small service low
but a cute girl in a summer dress Tased me.
I always thought I said tasted.
Tased me.
Hit me with a hammer and shoved me to the ground as I was
leaving.
So refreshing.
Must come back daily.
10 out of 10.
Thanks for the part of the 5 star stream, Binto.
Thank you.
You need a break after this game.
I do.
I do need a break.
I'm ready.
I'm ready to rest.
But we'll come back.
We'll come back to water park.
I will not rest until we have a big slide.
You know what I mean?
Thanks for the chaos.
Have a nice dinner.
I had tacos today and they were yummy.
I think that convinced me.
Virulent, you convinced me.
That's what I need to do.
The tacos, the tacos.
The tacos, the tacos, the tacos, the tacos.
Yeah.
Let's see.
Victoria Roman is doing the finale of Devil May Cry 3, so we
shall raid into her.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Thank you for the fun chill stream today.
Was it chill?
Was it chill for you guys?
Me running around like a chicken with my head cut off.
Vicky, Vicky, Vicky, Vicky.
Roman.
There she is.
All right.
Thank you guys.
She announced a new outfit.
Oh my god.
It's so cute.
You guys are not ready.
Yeah, don't taste us.
Taste every taco.
Happy tackling, boss!
Evil let us be gone.
Evil let us be gone!
What's up, everybody!
Thank you so much!
Have a good day, have a good day, have a good time zone.
Bye bye!
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you!
Bye bye!